For me, entrepreneurship has always been
the way.
Investing is important because it's the
only way you are going to be able to
rich and wealthy for your family. We can
>> we can
>> close the wealth gap
>> by working together.
>> Market Monday is the biggest investment
show ever.
>> My life has literally changed since
watching EM.
[music]
>> When you can make people money and you
can add value, they're going to be
forever indebted to you.
>> And I promise you this year I'm going to
make all even more money.
Disclaimer: Do your own research. Our
content is intended to be used and must
be used forformational purposes only.
It's very important to do your own
analysis before making any investment
based on your own personal
circumstances. You should take
independent financial advice from a
professional in connection with or
independently research and verify any
information that you find on our show
and wish to rely upon whether for the
purpose of making an investment decision
or otherwise. Let's build our knowledge,
our community, and our brokerage
accounts. Love is love.
Love is love. That's always the message.
Still is the message. Love is love.
Welcome back, y'all. It's Monday. A
glorious day. A glorious day. It's been
a It's been a beautiful, beautiful
weather weekend here in New York City.
Shout out to everybody in the city that
enjoyed it. Got a little rain on the
way, but that's okay. Uh Ian, my
brother, how are you feeling? It's been
an eventful week, huh?
Blessed and highly favored, my brother.
How are you? Back to you, Trevor Rashad.
[laughter]
>> I'm good. I'm good. Uh, it has been an
eventful week. Shotty, how you feeling?
>> Good. Good. Just happy to be here, you
know,
>> for sure.
>> We got a lot to talk about. Welcome
back. This is live. Shout out to the
market Monday's army. Um,
happy belated birthday to my niece. Her
birthday was on Friday.
>> Happy belated And happy advanced
birthday to my mother. Her her her
birthday is on Wednesday.
>> Happy birthday.
>> When we say shine a light on the world.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Got
>> season is upon us.
>> Yeah. Hey, hey, we got another birthday
here on the broadcasting show. Ian, how
you feeling? Birthday on on the way.
Blessed to see another one.
>> Blessed and highly favored. Thankful.
Yo, I can't lie. I'm I'm happy. Full of
joy. Uh, somebody in the comments said,
"Why y'all wearing black?" Cuz we keep
y'all in profit. That's why. [laughter]
No red. When you look at that, that net
and loss that P&L P&L be black if you
join back. [laughter] But I feel great.
I feel great. No 45minut show today. For
those of you who are worried, no 45minut
show today, extended. And oh, to my
Stock Club family, we was having tech
issues. We're going to make up and do
the Stock Club call tomorrow. Um, so I
love y'all. Stock club call on the way.
Shout out to everybody in uh EIL
University, all the earners that pulled
up uh to our class Thursday. It was an
eventful one. Actually, a pretty
welltime one. Uh we we talked about a
lot of things. We'll cover a little bit
of that tonight. But uh if you was
there, we appreciate the love and the
support. Shout out to the Red Panda
family. Uh that, you know, there's a lot
of commonalities, man. That's one of
them. People are investing at at an
all-time high, making money at all time
high. So, shout out to everybody that's
listening, but most importantly, those
who are executing, shout out to y'all.
>> Okay. We we we will talk about ARM, but
please don't spam the chat. We
definitely will talk about ARM, but
please don't spam the chat.
>> That's been warned. You've been warned.
[laughter]
>> Um, Wednesday.
>> Wednesday, Blackout, we got um
special guest. We have uh Teslan Figuro.
>> Been trying to tap in with her for a
minute. So, we got a lot to talk about
the Nolan Wells situation and man, so
many different things. Carmelo Anthony,
she got to tap us in and let us know
what's actually going on out here. Voter
rights and all that stuff. So, tap in
political episode on on Wednesday 9:00
live. That will be live.
>> And then Thursday, we back. We got uh
Ellis and Jasmine Suazo. Um, and they
are a couple and they specialize in
life insurance and they also have a life
insurance agency.
>> Yeah, dope couple.
>> So, we gonna be talking about life
insurance. We gonna be talking about
life insurance as a as a career path
and, you know, just general financial
planning. So,
>> that's a good one.
>> Yeah, you always love to see couples
build together, bring uh their own
strengths to to their union and create
business around that, man. So, it's
definitely a dope one. I'm always happy
to see sit down with couples and learn
from them and everybody's gonna get get
a treat. And shout out to everybody that
tapped into last week's episode, too.
The the John Morgan, Dan Morgan. It was
an incredible episode.
>> Yeah. Yeah, man. Shout out to everybody
that tapped into that. That That was
pretty dope. And and uh shout out to 19
keys, man. Shout out to 19 keys. He uh
dropped his album uh over the weekend,
man. I actually downloaded it and tapped
in a little bit. I ain't finished it
yet. Shout out to Stevie. Y he's
featured on a bunch of songs on there.
So shout out to Keys, man. Uh we are the
gods, man. Shout out to him.
>> And he had a dope interview with Shaka
dropped yesterday, too.
>> Salute the shock. Salute the shock
balls. All right, we ain't going to hold
you up. Just uh real quick,
>> um The Locks,
greatest rap group of all time. We can
have a conversation about it if you
would like, but uh the locks are opening
up in Vestfest. We're doing something
that we never did before. They actually
have a documentary which they debuted at
Tribeca Film Festival. So we are having
a um exclusive movie premiere of their
documentary. They will be there. Then
we're going to do a fireside chat with
them after Q&A and it's going to be a
whole vibe. Intimate. This is This is
Thursday night before Investfest starts.
This is Thursday night before Investfest
starts. It's an intimate vibe. Um if you
want to go, tickets are $35. the price
of a movie. Um, you can go to
investfest.com
and hit the locks tab. First come, first
serve. There's a few there's a few
tickets left, but that's going to be a
really dope way to kick off Investfest.
Shout out to Jada Kiss, Chic Luch, and
SP. [clears throat]
>> Yeah,
>> the Holy Trinity of rap.
>> Yeah, Trinity. That's actually the name
of the documentary. The documentary is
actually named Trinity. It's dope, man.
You talk about guys that we've watched
since I was 12, 13 years old, and to now
be sitting down with them, met them all
individually, but to have them all sit
down to talk about loyalty, to talk
about the career path, to talk about
consistency. It's a moment. It's
definitely one of them things I'mma
check off like, yo, I actually did that,
man. So, I'm excited. I'm excited. It's
gonna be a dope combo.
>> Somebody said Outcast over the locks. We
could We could
>> I was just about to say, you got to like
each other to be in the group still,
ain't it?
>> I think they do. And it's a No, it's you
can argue that. I'm not going to
disagree with that. I was actually just
listening to Aquimina before we started
this. So, I'm not mad at that take. It's
there's people
>> outcast amazing.
>> Yeah, there's a few groups in the
conversation.
>> I mean, yeah, you got Outcast, you got
the locks, you got Mob Deep.
>> For sure.
>> Sure. And we always have to put the
caveat. Are we counting Wu Tang as a
group? But I mean, Woo is definitely in
there one of the greatest of all time.
Even though y'all be slight Andre
because he don't have a quote unquote
solo.
>> Bro,
>> I don't what he did on what he did on
atlians. What he did on a
>> out of body. Yes. In 94.
>> Yeah.
>> They said they said I get on here and
say anything.
>> That's a great part of having Rashad.
[laughter]
>> Floppy. I got you. Not yet. Let me run
over real quick then. Floppy.
>> All right. Let me check with it.
>> All right. The last thing I'll say too
before we start the show is um night
life. If you are interested in nightife,
we have the parties open. Saturday is
official. I believe it's an avenue
official investfest afterparty on
Saturday. And then Sunday we having a
mansion party very very very exclusive
50 people only. And that's going to be
at a mansion in Atlanta and that's going
to be beverages is going to be provided
and food and you going to be what you
know it's going to be elite crowd. It's
going to be the vibe.
>> The who's who.
>> Yeah. The who's who for sure on Sunday.
So if you're interested in either one of
>> Huh?
>> What time?
>> I got you.
>> Go see Brian. [laughter] Everybody John
Morgan, Steve Harvey, everybody.
>> A fact. That is a fact. So, you can go
to this the event I want to go to.
>> You can go to investfest.com
and hit the afterparties tab if you're
interested in that. Ian, any
announcements?
>> Um, I got a special announcement later.
Uh, Stock Club prices are out. If you
are in Red Panda, if I made your money,
please put yes in chat. I will be adding
some this weekend as well. Um, as I said
earlier, Stock Club call will be redone
tomorrow because we was having a
technical issue. And if I made you
money, please put yes in chat. Let's
have an amazing show. And shout out to
Mike for the new layout, for upgrading
the idea and the visual experience.
Thank you so much.
>> Shout out to my my fam here in studio
helping me and guiding me through the
visual experience and audio experience.
I love y'all.
>> Let's have a great show.
>> Let's get it. Okay, let's investment
fact of the week. What is the investment
fact of the week?
>> Oh man. Uh semiconductor volatility
spiked to 61. So, for those of you who
don't know, in my Investfest
presentation on Sunday, if you want the
highest level of investment education at
Investfest,
um I will be covering how to research
sectorbased volatility to know when you
should be looking to buy the companies
in the in the underlying assets. But the
semiconductor volatility spiked to 61
today. Uh SanDisk is down 11, AMD down
11, Micron down 13. Um so this is a
great way to ga gauge if you have
volatility or there's a lot of erosion
in terms of pricing for a particular
stock. So um VIX is not that high
>> but a great tip is to look at individual
sector volatility to know if it's a
great time to buy or if there's great
decay in the market. New fun fact of the
week back to you sponsor buy investfest.
Get your tickets today.
Yo, I had this this uh this thought last
week and the my investment factor of the
week kind of comes off the back end of
watching Google report and have an
amazing quarter according to their CEO
Sunday PCA. Um and across the the board
right on every metric you would look at
this and say amazing quarter but it
inspired my my my investment factor of
the week which is either spend the money
expecting future growth or don't spend
the money and lose access to the future
of growth. And it's important that you
know the difference here because what
we're seeing now are there's capex
spends that are continue to increase
quarter after quarter. And what we're
seeing is companies being punished
quarter after quarter because of that
increased uh capex spend. We can talk
about the hyperscalers for sure, the
Metas, the Google's, the Microsofts, the
Amazons, but we can also talk about
Micron who also increased their capex
spend. Uh and so what does that mean?
either you're going to spend money to
scale and grow with the expectation of
that being returned at some point in the
near or short-term future or you're
going to not spend which has kind of
been the Zuckerberg approach where we're
going to spend because we can't afford
not to right because of the potential of
what AI is going to bring to the entire
economy and so we're in a tough spot
here especially for hyperscalers and
we'll see this week with with a lot of
big earnings we got Microsoft tomorrow
we got Meta tomorrow we got Amazon and
Apple coming up later in the week uh
Mastercard We saw a cadence report today
and had a really decent quarter. So,
it's a huge week for that. And companies
are going to have to figure out at what
point do they say, "Hey, we might have
to cut back spend so we can save our
stock price or they're just going to
keep doubling down quarter after quarter
and obviously be punished with with a a
pretty hefty pullback." If you look at
companies like Microsoft, if you look at
Tesla, which is down like 30%. that
there's something happening here and um
I don't know how they fix it or if they
want to because they're looking out
they're not looking what is this going
to look uh potentially look like for us
in the year the year of 2026
[clears throat] they're looking 2027 28
29 and so there is some some short-term
volatility which unfortunately we are
experiencing but
>> it's part of it we can't skip this part
>> really quick Google has negative free
cash flow first time since quarter 26 I
don't want you guys to confuse was
Google and Microsoft capex spin with
that of Intel, Oracle and those who are
not hyperscalers or a tier. The real
issue that we're having here is that no
one wants to say it, but part of that
private credit bubble collapse that
could happen. A lot of it is being
poured over from the AI spend. Um, I
know Google got punished unfavorably,
but it's a bigger contagion issue of
everyone spending on AI and no one has
told you how they're going to make a
return. No business owner wants to say
it, but there isn't an LLM that you can
just fully automate your business to. I
wish there was. Um, but don't get rid of
Google. And I've actually in Stock Club
moved up Google's ranking in Stock Club
um over Amazon as a result. But don't
confuse Google and Microsoft's cap spend
with
B and CT player C players as a result.
>> I think you made a that's a very
important distinction and I talked about
this the other night so it's important
I'll bring it here to the market
Monday's audience that cash burn has two
different phases. There's a cash burn
for companies who can't make the money,
right, and have to figure out ways to
try to get income into their companies.
And then there's the other type of cash
burn where you're making money, right?
But you're actually investing more than
you're making. And so Google is the
latter, right? So if we look at their
metrics, they beat on revenue, they beat
it on adjusted earnings per share. They
beat on the cloud revenue, right? They
beat on operating income, but the capex
spend was negative almost six billion.
So they're bringing in money from all
the avenues, right? the YouTube, the
cloud, uh from search, but they said
this is the first quarter in the history
in the history of the company that they
had a negative cash burn. And so this
goes back to that cap export uh story.
>> We saw them have a positive day today,
but they got hit pretty hard after they
recorded.
>> Um but I'm with you. It's still my my
favorite company of the year. I think we
said that at the top that I said Google
be my company of the year. Uh and all
the metrics still show that. Listen,
Google generated 60 billion from
YouTube, which is more than Netflix, and
20 billion from subscriptions.
Like, I don't if there's one company
management wise, you don't have to
really worry about and has shown they
could have adjusted. And we'll talk
about Apple later, but Google has still
operated in the way that I wish Apple
would have. Um, Google's going to be
fine. I think we're going to have a
recalibration
in the days of just everything going up
5 700% because they were spending on AI.
That story is going away. The new story
is which I've been asking for a year.
How you going to get return?
>> Yeah.
>> So,
>> yeah. Well, it's just quarter after
quarter now. How are we going to get
return?
>> Um, okay. Mike, the thing keeps flashing
on the bottom. I'm not sure. um
>> flashing
>> that earn it says earn your lead in Ian
and Dunlap. It's like it's flashing a
little bit.
>> That's cuz the future is bright, my
brother.
>> That's a fact. That is a fact. Let's
talk about the trading tip of the week.
What's the trading tip of the week?
>> You're only going to get better if you
trade in front of an audience or a group
of people. My assignment for you in
August and September, especially for my
futures traders, especially if you're in
Red Panda, you've been trying to like
duck showing your portfolio and your
performance. I want you to get on
Streamyard or YouTube live and I want
you for 30 days to show your practice in
your live trade setup. It's exhausting.
It is frustrating, but sometimes the
only way you get better, we need to be
bring back shaming to a certain degree,
right, in society. But [laughter]
um and even though some have tried to
deal with us in a positive format, if
you are have to be accountable in front
of a group, shout out to Sesh and
Mon'nique, um Daniel Leslie, like in
2016, every week I had to trade in front
of them, right? So that made my results
be better as a result. Um Tai and Edwin
had put up a post earlier today, too.
And um the genesis of me getting really
good at it is having to do it in front
of someone. So if you have not gotten
the edge that you want to get together
with eight people, you guys collectively
trade together, agree on entry, agree on
exit, and only take that price. And then
I think if you start to do that for a
60-day or 30-day period, you'll get a
lot uh higher return in the market as a
result.
>> Valid. Valid. I I I would think my mine
is uh follow your trend lines and
downsize your allocations. Right. So,
we're we're watching
>> like the number of shares in in options.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's important um be
>> because when we're looking at especially
the the memory sector right now we're
watching 40% pullbacks, 50% pullbacks. I
know human nature says, "Hey, I need to
buy low, right? I have to buy low." And
that's true, but that doesn't mean that
I'm pouring like the largest allocation
into these numbers because the trend
line is showing us that there could be
more downturn, right? And so we want to
watch those trend lines. If you're
buying shares, you might want to ease
into the positions here, right? Because
you might be able to get better prices.
If you're buying options contracts,
we're not buying 10, we might be buying
two, right? And in the event that we
start to see that trend line go back up,
then we can allocate more. But I want
people to really understand the
technical sides, watch those trade
lines, follow where those EMAs are
going, and then make appropriate
decisions, right? If you don't, then
that's like, hey, you hear that that
analogy, hey, who wants to catch the
falling knife? Nobody wants to do that.
People want to get it at low prices. But
we don't have to commit all the way, all
of our allocation. Yes, you can add some
positions, you can add some shares,
maybe buy one or two contracts. Just
don't pour everything into it when you
when you see downward trends like this.
You've been reading my notes from
investments. I swear to God. [laughter]
Cut it in the third. Like one of the
great lessons too to prevent that like
you said, and this is one of the reasons
why people get out too early. Let's say
if you can afford 100 shares, you buy
100. If you would have just did a third
of that, let's say 30 just to round it
out, it doesn't hurt as bad as you going
full port and now you're down 22%.
Opposed if you cut your portion size
down and especially on the trading side.
Uh we can talk about the market
manipulation and single stock futures
here later, but you have to be more
cautious, especially with like when this
China story keeps popping up cuz even
with the Kimmy and Deep Seek,
>> they're telling you the future of what's
going to happen. At some point,
something open source is going to flip
in China's favor and it's going to erode
our market. But what will save you a lot
of time is if you don't um trade full
port and and knock it down the third.
But I'll talk about that more Sunday
after it comes off stage in the best
fest.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's interesting because we
talked about it last week where history
doesn't repeat itself, but it does
rhyme. [clears throat]
>> So it feels like semi specifically
memory are having their deepseat moment,
right? Like y'all can y'all can remember
January of 2025 cuz it it felt crazy,
right? Deep Seek, here it is. They're
going to create better GPUs at a cheaper
price. And then you watch the entire
semiconductor space fall until you
realize that that they really are not
going to be able to do that. They're
still going to have to spend with
certain companies and and use certain
things to actually be able to put out
that level of compute. And obviously,
you see a rebound. And now it feels
especially with the open models now and
China today uh having CX CMXT uh debut
or IPO
>> it feels like oh here's here's the
memory sector. So it it doesn't repeat
itself but it sure does rhy and if you
saw the outcome of that then you should
feel okay we've seen this before let's
just stay disciplined.
>> Um let's talk about arm since that was a
question. So what is the deal with arm?
I mean, this is again in that semi
space. I think we we've had a a hell of
a runup, right? We were in this call
probably in in the early 200s. I know it
ran up to 350, now pulled back. That
story hasn't changed. When when we're
talking about manufacturing, we're
talking about encasing. Armor is going
to play a major role. If you look at
every semiconductor, it probably has its
tie to it in terms of how it's being
encased. Um, so you when you look at I
used to call them motherboards and
that's the best way I could probably
tell people now. But if you look at it,
yeah, there's certain components. Uh,
there's connectivity, right? There's
memory, there's a GPU, and there's
transistors. And all those ARM is pretty
much playing a role in in putting these
pieces together. So, it's a company
again that I'm long-term on for sure.
It's pulled back here. Still hasn't got
to the lows of where we bought it at.
So, just be patient with this story. I
we'll we'll talk about even more when we
talk about the China piece and how it's
affecting the market,
>> but just be patient with especially with
these American companies.
>> Just be patient.
>> And ARM didn't even pull back the most.
Like if you look at Sandis, Micron, ASM,
like we have some deeper concerns.
Um I I get it. Like if you're trading
it, I get the concern. But as a result,
if you're holding a long term, if you
loved it at 410, I don't know how you
don't love it at 266. If it goes to
22515, I absolutely love it. But this is
my other point. Hold for long term. I'm
begging you. All the weekly rotation
things that y'all be trying to do, stop
it. We really go to 45 minutes show.
Like there is no weekly or monthly
rotation, this sector will be okay. But
two things have to be addressed. What is
the return on investment that they're
going to get from AI? And if the
compression and spending slows down,
will the chipmakers be affected? Yes,
but they'll find another industry to
attack and they'll be a okay because the
chips are too vital to business
infrastructure. And then second, what
are we going to do about the open-
source modeling that China and also
where are they getting some of the data
to build an open source, but I'll tackle
that after open the open source piece is
important because the same day that they
announced open source, Nvidia says,
great where are you building that
software on?
>> Guess who they're gonna have to call?
They got to come back home. Yep.
>> You got to come back home because they
have they are the platform that is the
is platforming all all the software. And
so they they gave you a list and and
maybe I'll put it up in in my stories
tonight. They gave you a list of the
companies and some of them should look
very familiar, right? You saw Dell, you
saw Cadence, you saw Synopsis, you saw
Palunteer, you saw Palo Alto, you saw
Crowd Strike. All these companies,
they're saying like, "Hey, open source
fine. That doesn't hurt us. Bring it
on." Um, and so that's why it's
interesting when you when you watch
these pullbacks and you understand it.
Number one, efficiency is going to
always be paramount. But number two is
scalability, right? Like if you're going
to build cheaper models, and I've always
said this, right? Faster does not always
mean better, right? When you do things
with speed, you lack
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, just remember that.
>> Um,
>> you got to make some really quick,
Rashad. Uh, before you go to the next
top, I got to ask. I'd be remiss if I
didn't. Investfest is right around the
corner. Can you give people, you and
Troy both, maybe two examples of great
networking at Investfest in order to be
able to build their business for 26 and
27?
>> Uh, yes, for sure. Be mindful of um who
you want to network with. I had this
call with UI University last week and it
could be overwhelming, especially if
you're an introvert, but that's why you
have to be um strategic. So it's like,
okay, we know that you you specifically
want to
>> network with real estate people.
>> You should be going MG's doing a real
estate workshop.
>> You should be going to that. You should
be going to a real estate panel. You
should identify like when you talk to
people and it's like, you know, okay,
you do plumbing. Okay, maybe I can help.
Or you do something that's not totally
related. It's not like you don't just
brush them off, but you put more of an
emphasis on who you're actually looking
for. So that's important. People want to
network. What does that even mean,
network? Like you that's just you're
just open to meeting anybody. Like if
you want to meet a specific group of
people, you got to put yourself in in
that specific group and area. That's the
good thing. There's panels on
everything. So people most of the time
if they're in that panel, they're either
in the industry or they're interested in
the industry. That's that would be my
take. And then the next thing you said
too, um, add value.
>> I always say it don't lead with, you
know, hey, can I call you on Thursday?
And it's like, look, what do you need
help with? How can I help? if I can help
and you know lead with adding value
first. That's a great way to build a
relationship.
>> Yeah, I would say uh build across. Um I
think being intentional about building
across is is something that you know
especially with the the younger audience
we've watched them do it, right? They
they come to Invest with intentionality
and now I mean we're seeing people do it
more and more, right? It the people on
stage are great. The information is is
bar none the best. But there's somebody
who's receiving the information at the
same time you are that might spark
something in them. And so building
across the table is important. Uh moving
with intentionality and being prepared,
you know, [clears throat] it it you
know, and you've probably experienced it
too, I'm sure. There you run into
somebody and they say, "Oh my gosh, I
didn't think I would see you. I don't
even know what to say." So be prepared,
be intentional, lead with value, and
network across the board. And you never
know who you're going to meet, man. That
that's the beauty of it. Like there's so
many stories that we don't know that
have actually happened, businesses that
have started uh relationships that have
started uh investing pitches and
investment inside of companies that are
happening because of people who are
like-minded saying, "Hey, let's work
together. How can we do it? Let's start
this now."
>> And my goal, my goal is to bring a
billionaire to the vendor marketplace. I
think we have a very good chance of that
happening. There's two billionaires that
will be there. John Morgan and Mike
Novagrats. One on Saturday, one on
Sunday. I think we have a very good
chance of bringing at least one
potentially two.
>> I think they both to do it. They're both
to do it.
>> Yeah. I think I think we got a good
chance of bringing two billionaires that
in the marketplace.
Man, that's a great opportunity because
they they're gonna be meeting people.
They're gonna be talking to people.
>> Yeah. And and and obviously they're
there, but you know else is there? Their
team,
>> right? Their team. And so when they're
on stage or when you see them walk in,
figure out who their entourage is,
right? It could be their son or it could
be their daughter that they're walking
in with and that person might just be,
you know, patroning at the in the vendor
marketplace. That might be an
opportunity, right? When nobody, hey, I
saw you walk in with so and so. Hey, my
name is Right. Like, meet the team,
attack the perimeter, and you never know
where it can go.
>> Shout out to K. She said, uh, I made all
my money back just from just from
networking.
>> That's fire.
>> Absolute. And and to that if you run
into anyone that you want to meet,
>> treat the people who are around them
like stars as well.
>> Don't skip past the assistant. Don't
skip past the family. Greet everyone.
Cuz to them, they are the star. So if
you mishandle them, you're not going to
get in great favor with the person that
you want access to. Some of you have had
to learn this the hard way. Treat
everyone that you meet in that inner
circle like they are the star because
they are ultimately
>> when we get in a sprinter or they get
back on a plane, they're gonna what you
think of this person. Should we do this
or not?
>> It's often going to go to their
decision- making.
>> You you never and and this is I'm glad
you said that. You don't know how many
times AB has sat down with us and said,
"Look, you see this young lady over
here? She's been waiting for y'all.
She's such a sweet lady. She has this
great idea. Yo, you is right if we call
her over?" All right. if he feels great
about it and they've treated him with
that level of respect,
>> it's it's a no-brainer because we trust
him with that type of information. And
so a lot of times if AB is like, "Yo,
I'm not sure." No, no, no. They they was
kind of rude to to this person or that
person. All right,
let's not do it right now.
>> It's important, man.
>> That's a fact. All right. Um, we'll talk
more about Investfest later, but ASML
faces uh some stiff competition when it
comes to China. So, what is the deal
with that? Mike, can we update the um
topics to ASML? Thank you.
>> All right. So, there's a couple things
here. Competition.
I think yes. I think yes. Long-term that
that is competition. What has happened?
So, the Chinese state backed company um
they've decided that they're going to
produce their own DUV. Now, this is
important to distinguish the two, right?
They are making their own DUV machine.
This lithography machine. Why is that
important? Well, ASML is predominately
the the largest world maker in the DUV
machine, but they're the only maker of
the EUV machine, which is very important
to understand. Why is that important?
Well, the distinction is in terms of
what they can produce. And so, think of
the DUV machine when we talk about
nanometers like how much this wafer can
hold or how the size of it, you're
talking about between 148 nanometers to
about 193.
>> Okay. an EUV machine, which is what TSM
is using, which is what Nvidia is using,
they can go down to a 13 nanometer,
right? And so when you're talking about
compact size and efficiency, the EUV
machine is the one. Now, why is that
important? Because that machine costs
between 150 to $400 million per machine.
Per machine. Think about that.
[clears throat]
Right? So now, how many machines is
China being built? And we talked about
this the other day. Remember maybe a
year ago we said there was some Chinese
quote unquote allegedly. Shout out to
Kobe.
>> Allegedly.
>> Allegedly spies that were in the
Netherlands trying to figure out the
trade seekers of how to build this
machine. Well, maybe they have, but they
didn't get the EUV. They got the DUV.
>> That that's important because China has
about five of those five of those DUV
machines that'll be online by the end of
this year. By the end of 2027, they're
saying that they should have 20. Right.
So from a technological standpoint that
was that's an older model to where we're
going with advanced chips specifically
GPUs and now the CPUs. The EUV machines
ASML has 250 of those that are systems
that are running right now in the world.
TSM
>> owns over 100 plus of them. So when
we're talking about manufacturing large
scale high bandwidth memory put onto a
GPU, TSM is going to be the
manufacturing partner as of now. And
we'll talk about maybe a little bit more
with some of the competition inside
there. Samsung is number two, but
there's a distinction. So from a
short-term standpoint, it feels like oh
my gosh, here comes a competitor, but
again, technologically, they're it's not
in the same realm just yet. long term.
Now, if they can figure out to, hey,
we're going to build our capacity for
the DUV machines, that's great. They can
they'll be able to build um some
compute, that's great. They won't need
TSM as much. Great.
>> Guess what the world is using,
right? They they're using the highest
form of semiconductor, which is still
being produced by TSM being manufactured
by TSM and being being created by Nvidia
and all the other semiconductors in the
world, uh AMD. So, that's important.
Now, does it hurt ASML? Yeah, because
[clears throat] on top of it, like the
DUV machines,
>> because they weren't able to sell the
EUV to China, they started selling those
they started selling the DUVs. And so,
if they make their own, will you lose
some of the profit from China? Yeah,
absolutely. But long term, they're
looking at it, hey, our biggest money
maker and where the future is going is
going to be in the EU EUV machine, the
lithography machine. So when that if
that starts to get cannibalized and we
start to see companies make that because
right now they do literally this is a
monopoly. They're the only company in
the world that makes that machine then
we have a bigger story.
>> Yeah. I think um it it's one thing we
have to remember because China is a
better manufacturer and they have better
tech than us. This is the attempted
gathering of the final infinity stone.
China want to make sure that it's
independent um and not relying upon us.
So, this is a big geopolitical issue. I
know everyone says Micron now has
arrival.
Um, CM CXMT went up 400% in one day,
yada yada. Those are all headlines that
sound great,
>> but the underlying story is the spend
and the first company in America that
tells you what the spend is because now
Nvidia isn't the sexy story anymore. I
think there's going to be a stable
option and we're even seeing a rotation
heavily into Apple for underspend
because now it's almost like an index
plus or ETF plus as a safety yield play.
Um I do think at some point China is
going to nail one of these issues, but I
don't think it's been done yet. Um, a
lot of the market being drugged down is
because of the reckless spending, even
though it's good debt. For all my good
debt pioneers who nail that into the
floor every time you can. Um, it's going
to bring the market down. I think August
and September may be a little bit rough,
but this is not the time to rotate out
of the companies that are going to
change your life. It'll be a massive
mistake if you do. And earlier somebody
asked a question, um, you discourage
people from weekly and monthly sector
rotation, but how do you reconcile that
with the idea that they're companies
that are going generational runs? I'm
going to say it again. If you can't hold
a great company for a generation, you
don't deserve generational wealth. A lot
of these companies that went on
generational runs are now down 40 and
50%. And most people did not get in at
the bottom. They start getting in
towards the top and now they're bleeding
down. It is very difficult even with AI,
even with being a good technical trader
to catch a lot of these bottoms. So if
you're rotating out of one thing into
another and that's why a lot of times
when I say something people I'll be
like, "Hey, fire Tim Cook."
>> This was two years ago, Apple, not now.
But hold the stock. Some people be like,
"No, well you said Apple's going to
fall." That's cuz you weren't holding it
for a long time and you weren't
listening. So, um, you can't rotate on a
weekly or monthly basis because you
don't have the skill set or the
technology to do it for you fast enough
because even if you try to automate it,
there's a lot of slippage regardless of
what broker you use. So, hope for the
long term.
>> I called I called him earlier today. We
got I got some words for Tim Cook and
the team at Apple.
>> I got I got I got a few words. We We And
when we get to that China chip market
surge, I got some words for them. But
good good point.
>> We went through that so you won't have
to go through that.
>> No, no, no. Not that type of smoke. Not
that type of smoke. No. Not that type of
smoke.
>> Okay.
>> From intellectual smoke. [laughter]
>> Gotcha.
>> But the the somebody brought a great
point in the chat. They said that TSM
has said, you know what, we're going to
try to shy away from the ASM ASML
machines because they do cost a lot. And
so you start to think who becomes your
customer base if the largest
manufacturing packaging company decides
to shy away. That is potentially
potentially be a problem for ASML. um
which is not an American company. Uh so
we'll see. We got to watch that
carefully. The the China news is news.
The TSM news would be more important to
me because that's the the customer
that's buying in bulk, right? You're
talking about 150 million per machine
and they have over 100 plus. Samsung is
number two, but not even in the realm of
where TSM is at. That is concerning. If
you lose that customer, all right, we
got to make a call to the Netherlands.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. All right. Okay. The moment
has come. Wait, really quick before we
>> really quick. Let me squeeze this one
in. You can go, my brother. My
apologies. Floppy. Uh, to the person who
asks, "What percentage of bonds should
you have in your portfolio if you're
under 35?" None.
None. [laughter]
>> Zero play.
>> I've been telling y'all for since 2020,
the bond market has been eroding.
The institutional investors don't even
want bonds anymore. If you trade UB or
ZB, shout out to y'all in Red Panda.
The bond market has been in perpetual
freef fall for five years. And shout to
Ben Carlson, shout to Josh, shout to
Atlas Barry, uh, shout to Michael Bur.
Everyone I talk to give me pieces of the
real answer. I have not gotten the real
answer to why the bond market has been
free falling for f I always like to go
back to this, Rashad. But if I met you
in 2010, I told you for 5 years, the
bond market is going to fall flat.
You're you like you're a [__] scam
artist.
>> And here we are. If tech was in free, if
QQQ was in a negative draw down for five
years, y'all would be trying to find me
in Houston. I don't know what the
contingent event is, but no, you don't
want exposure. Maybe when you're older
and if you can get a select product from
UBS that guarantees a return on
investment if you're a high net worth
investor, go for it. But no, zero. Back
to you, Rashad. My apologies.
>> 2010 that that's that's the Colorado
era.
>> For sure. [laughter]
>> For sure.
>> Hey, what's up, man?
>> Okay.
>> How you feeling?
>> Public service announcement.
Yeah,
>> let's get into this.
>> Oh, we almost at 45 minutes anyway. Go
ahead. [clears throat]
[laughter]
>> My time.
>> Let's get into this. First and foremost,
man, shout out to the Breakfast Club.
Always a pleasure whenever we um have an
opportunity to go up there. So, you
know, we went to the Breakfast Club and
there was a lot of um
controversy, per se. Um yeah, I I think
it it sparked a lot of conversations,
both negative, positive, and
indifferent.
you got anything you want to say?
>> Yeah, I you know what I the only thing I
would say is that I'm always open to
conversation. I I also would say that I
think
listening back to it, right? If you
listen to the the full conversation I
and you understand what we were talking
about in context, the conversation makes
sense. I think when people heard city of
Atlanta come out of my mouth, I think
they internalized it as I meant the
people of Atlanta. And by no means did I
mean the people of Atlanta, but sure we
love Atlanta. We visit there. Over 60%
of our company lives there. So it's
nothing against the city of Atlanta in
terms of the people. We got great people
there and there are great people there.
My concern and the puzzling thing was
the city officials and we've have a
we've had conversations with them uh
since this breakfast club. So that I
want to clear that part up cuz I I'm
like I'm not sure how they're confusing
that. But if you are, let's just make
this clear. By no means was was I
saying, and I can speak for Shotti as
well in terms of that, by no means were
we saying the people of Atlanta. I think
it was very clear of the people we were
talking to from our standpoint, city
officials and the corporations that
exist inside the city. So, like I said,
we've had conversations. Um, so
hopefully that clears things up uh in in
terms of that. Rashad Rashad.
>> Okay.
So, you know, I was going to take a
different approach on this, but you
know, there's a few people that I
actually do listen to and I respect
their opinion. And, you know, a few of
the OGs that I I actually they they they
actually
ask
>> put that call in,
>> they asked
if it could be if it could be
communicated in in a very diplomatic
way. And out of respect for my OG's,
I'm I I I said, "Okay, I said okay.
>> I love it.
[sighs]
>> Don't regret."
[laughter]
>> I I know you.
>> Nope.
>> No, no, no. I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm
not. But what I'm what I am going to say
is this though, right? Um,
we all we did was just answer a question
on somebody else's platform.
We have our own platform
that we can weaponize if we want to,
but we haven't.
So, I don't want anybody to think that
we're a victim
because we haven't said anything. Like,
we've we only just said one thing and
that just went viral on somebody else's
platform.
So, I'm against black-on-black crime
100%.
But I just don't want people to think
that we can just get picked apart cuz we
can speak as well.
One thing,
>> but
>> one thing. The second thing is
anybody with a brain,
having a brain is very uncommon these
days. They asked us a question. We gave
them an answer. And to the crowd who's
like, "Well, you were dead wrong because
the Georgia World Congress Center is not
owned by the city and you you didn't you
just rushed to the city. You never even
spoke to the city ever. All it takes is
a quick Google search to know that we
had a press conference with the mayor
three three years ago. Obviously, we
spoke to the city. We've been speaking
to the city for six years. Out of
respect for the city and out of respect
for my OG's,
>> city officials,
>> the city officials and respect for my
OG's,
I will leave it at that when it comes to
city hall. But the idea that we just
jumped out the window and had no
[clears throat] idea what we were
talking about and never spoke to anybody
at city government, like I said, I mean,
>> a quick Google search would have seen
that we actually did a press conference
with the mayor. So, how do you think
that we never spoke to anybody? Common
sense, but sense is not common.
Now, that's that's all I have to say
about the city hall thing. I could say
more,
>> but in in good faith,
I'm not. Now, [snorts] to the Clippers
community, cuz this this really started
to go viral when somebody clipped a
small portion of actually what I said
and made it seem like I was talking
about the city of Atlanta and
the crazy thing about it, it was very
misleading. So, I end up speaking to the
guy that did it and the this so for you
guys to have information, right? Because
you need to understand how this world
works. So, it was a very misleading and
a very dangerous way that this was
presented and got a lot of negative
backlash. So, I'm like, "Yo, what's up
with you, bro?" He's like, "First and
foremost, I've been to every Investfest.
I got my book signed. I'm in a picture
with you. You know, I've loved you since
day one." I said, "Yo, you doing all of
this, then why would you purposely
misrepresent what I said?" That's
actually dangerous. All it takes is one
crazy person to say, "You dissing my
city. You down on their luck." Like, you
actually put me in harm's way. He's
like, "Yo, I'm just I'm just a clipper.
I just did it for content."
>> View, baby. We talked about us fans. But
it says a lot about the times that we
and that's why I'm not even explaining
anything anymore because it's like you
see yo you know how many people had no
idea no context at all saw a 10-second
clip and this is from somebody who's
actually a fan and who told me to my
face over the phone bro I just did it
for content I'm sorry but it's just I
just needed to get views
so
>> few days
>> it says a lot about the times that we
in. And for you fake professionals out
there
>> that took the opportunity,
>> I hate you guys so much, [laughter] man.
I hate you guys so much. And the time
will come cuz I watch everything. I saw
your post. I saw your comments.
The time will come. And just know,
you've been hating on us for a long time
because you have no influence. You have
no audience. Doesn't matter what college
you went to. You're broke. You're corny.
And I I really do hate you from the
bottom of my heart. I hate you guys so
much.
>> That's a strong word.
>> That's a bit much, brother. You said you
don't believe in black-on-black crime.
You can't do you can't brother. My
brother
>> over over misalignment, my brother.
>> Because it comes from hate.
>> It comes from hate. That's why I got to
hate them because it comes from hate.
And it's variety of different people.
It's not one person. It's I've watched
everything. I've seen people that have a
hundred like they put a post up and they
got a hundred views, but I'm one of the
hundred people that saw it.
>> I'm taking notes. I've been doing
>> I saw a bunch of Yeah,
>> I've been taking notes for years
>> and it always comes back and they're
like, "Can I speak at Investfest?" And
[laughter] I'm like,
>> "Screenshot time." Remember this?
November 18th, 2024.
>> Kick rocks.
>> Nah, man. And I love y'all
[__] man. Friend of fo, you're
all my mother, man. [clears throat]
>> So, that being said,
>> they got they got a job to do.
>> How I'll end this is that if you really
listen to the clip, we actually
advocating for for entrepreneur. That's
why it's really hard to help black
people if you really want to be honest.
Cuz the whole clip is like if we having
a hard time with city governments and
with Fortune 500 companies and we are
who we are and we own the Breakfast
Club, y'all don't stand a chance. That's
the whole point. That's what you should
have got out of it. You want to turn
into a oh a New York verse Atlanta or
he's diss this in Atlanta. That's the
that's honestly the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard in my life. Like you talking
about what what have we done for
Atlanta. What else can we do? We have 37
food trucks that come every single year
from Atlanta that make their month. We
got 215 vendors that come commission
free that sell their products and their
services. We done donated to Howard to
um to Morehouse University to Spellelman
University. We we give um we giving
20,000 courtesy of Ian $20,000 away to a
high school student from Atlanta,
Georgia for the pitch competition.
>> And for every child who's in in
attendance on Thursday, I'll be giving
$250 away in partnership with Square to
fund a kids account to so they can
invest. This was done before this blow
up, too, by the way.
>> We done did we done did the turkey
driaway. Shout out to EO University.
You know what? It's really it's it's and
I see people like, "Yo, these guys
should be put in jail. Screw them. They
should never be allowed back in
Atlanta."
Okay. It's disheartening when you hear
>> It's heartbreaking. Yeah.
>> What have we done? What have we done but
help? Oh, you guys are platforming
grifters. We had three people out of
5,000. Bernie Maidoff was the president
of NASDAQ. [sighs]
Are you like That's what I'm saying.
Like I hate y'all so much. I hate y'all
from the bottom of my heart. I really
hate y'all so so much because
>> not the public. He's not talking about
the public.
>> No market Monday. Market Mondays is
family. I love you guys. But I'm just
saying like, yo, we done did everything
that we possibly can to bring people out
the dark ages and introduce you to
billionaires and taught you how to trade
options and taught you about real estate
and taught you about a 203k loan. And
y'all want to look at the the any little
blemish to try to misrepresent
misrepresent a person and destroy their
character on a public stage. And it's
it's actually embarrassing and it's
disgusting.
But
when we go low, they go high. And to the
last thing, my last thing
>> to the people that says, "Well, we're
Investfest is the biggest party." Once
again, I hate you guys so much, too,
because there's never been an event like
Investfest. You can make all the list
that you want that's out of context. You
got sports events on there that nobody
even heard of. We never even heard of
these events.
You're a bozo for making that list by
the way. Um but
no, we the we're the ones that brought
the millionaires. We're the ones that
that have a pitch competition for
125,000 could be 250,000.
We're the ones that got the the food
trucks and the vendors. We're the ones
that got the presentations from Ian
Dunlap and 19 keys and we're the ones
that brought you John Morgan. Y even
heard of John. You don't even know who
he actually looked like. You just heard
his name before. Mike Novagrats. And and
bro, we brought Square and they're
giving away $100,000 of Bitcoin for free
inside the vendor marketplace to use
with vendors.
>> Shout out to Square.
>> Invest with Invesco. QQQ. Invesco will
be at Investfest hiring people when
nobody's getting hired right now.
>> Yeah, I got a lot of nerve, man. They
got a lot of nerve and a lot of
audacity. But Friday is all day
education at Investfest. All day
education, seminars, workshop, black
shop, black rock real estate, stocks,
all of that.
>> Saturday is all day. We got Steve
Harvey. We got
Look, just Google it, man. Sunday we got
Ian Dunlab. We got Mike Novagrass, we
got Serena Williams, we we got we got
John Morgan, we got Tashana Ducket, the
only black woman who's a CEO of a
Fortune 100 company. And the last thing
that I'm saying, [laughter]
if you want to know what we going to do
for Atlanta or for any place,
shout out to our partners at Block.
>> Yes.
>> When when somebody comes with hate, you
just leave with love.
>> Yeah.
>> Block is sponsoring 200 free tickets to
Investfest. So for the crowd that says,
"Oh, it's a money grab. What have you
done?" Now we just going to give it a
Now we just going to give it away. 200
people, first come, first serve. Enter
code block at checkout. The price is 0.
Make sure that you can come. Please
don't take it from somebody that can
actually come. It would be helpful if
you lived in Atlanta or the greater
Atlanta region because then we know that
you can actually come. If you don't have
plans on coming, just don't get the
ticket. But the last thing I'll say is,
man, it's been seven years. [laughter]
We giving away free tickets to
Investfest. 200 free tickets. Thank you
to our partners at Block and it's
perfect timing. Um, you can go to
Investfest.com
and you can enter code block. If you
want to change your life, you got the
singles room. Brother met his wife last
year. What more can you do? VIP night.
Please wear a black tie. It is a black
tie affair. It has a tuxedo with shoes
and a black tie
>> with shoes.
>> Shoes. Oh, that was you. Is that your
last thing?
>> Cold block. [laughter]
>> Shout. You have four last things. Yo,
man. Seriously, shout out to Block
though. That that's an amazing
opportunity for a bunch of people who
who just want to um come to Investfest.
And if you're watching this right now on
on YouTube live, you can scan that that
QR code, use the code block at checkout.
Man, again, shout out to them.
Obviously, they're part of our pitch
competition for our youth, but they
also,
>> and I don't I don't want to misunder mis
uh represent this, but they are actually
not only giving away money in the vendor
marketplace, but they are helping
sponsor accounts for our young adults
who will be attending uh the the teen
investfest. So, we got over 400
students, 215 are coming from uh the
Atlanta metro area. Um and so, every kid
is getting an account, which is
important, right? when we talk about
financial education, you actually are
practicing it in real time. And so, who
knows what that does for that those
young teens um outside of them being
able to meet teens from other areas of
the world because we are bringing down
over 150 uh teens from New York. Shout
out to Councilman Riley. Shout out to
shout out to G for facilitating all all
the events that are surrounding um the
kids invest fest, our local community.
We're bringing down 60 people. Everybody
is starting with an account, man, which
is incredible. I wish I would have had
it at 16, 17, but these kids will have
it. So, that's what it's about, man.
Shout out to Black for helping us out
with that. And Ian, shout out to you. I
know you said you going to match that.
So, we appreciate you, my brother.
>> Yeah. $250 for every kid who comes so
they can get their investing journey
pushed. And then I'm going to find a way
as well to be able to guide them through
investing as well. So, them and their
parents, so they'll be okay. Um, for
those of you who may say Rashad was a
bit emotional in Durant, the other part
of the entrepreneurs never get to say is
the heartbreak that you face by trying
to help your own people. Number two, for
all my entrepreneurs listening tonight,
the real sector rotation that matters is
this understand how long you should stay
in one market for how for a certain
period of time. You have to research
viability of a market and how long that
total addressable market is there. If
you go to it in the LLM, you can
research. Like for all my wrestling
fans, it seems like Hulk Hogan and Steve
Austin was on top forever. Steve Austin
had a four-year run. Most media
companies have a four to sixyear run
until a move or decision has to be made.
So [laughter]
45 minute show bulk record.
Like let's go to to to the next joint
here.
>> We have 54 minutes. Come on.
>> I want I want this China piece. Um
because I I know we we got a special uh
visitor uh coming on with us but or
guest with us but uh let's let's do this
S&P pullback outlook u because we are
hearing a lot of noise. It keeps trading
between 7,400 and 7500. I've seen a lot
of analysts which is interesting. They
haven't lowered the outlook for the the
the year guidance. It's still sitting at
8,200 to 8,300. What's your thoughts on
the S&P pullback outlook?
I
>> I think people are too worried about a
8day pullback on the Meta had their
longest uh consecutive day draw down of
eight days in a row. But if you're
focused on the long term, you don't care
about eight days. Now, I'm not saying
this as a person that is dismissive of a
pattern as a elite technician. If you go
back to June 9th, we got to 7250
and some change.
>> Could we breach those levels?
Potentially. But I think uh July into
August is usually a rough month. If we
had to spat in October or November, I
may have a different concern.
>> Once again, it is a midterm year.
There's a politician who may have passed
that they have not announced yet. We
have a route in China. AI spend is
incredibly high. Truth be told, for the
market that we in, we if it was not for
the AI capex spend, we would be in
recession, which they won't say. So,
it's not as bad as it could be.
>> Yeah.
>> Um I I do see a world we can fall to
7356 down to 7330.
great bond opportunity. But my biggest
concern about us doing a show every week
and me putting three hours a day into
prepping and writing the show is you're
not hearing the message of long-term.
And I truly believe most people don't
want to be financially free. They just
want to be able to spend money
recklessly and [__] it off on demand.
I'm not here for you, respectfully.
>> Yeah.
>> So for for those of you who are looking
to invest longterm, could it go to those
levels? Yes. But I do I think by
September and October we'll be up.
>> Absolutely. Hold for the long term. You
can't have generational wealth if you
hold for generational wealth.
>> Yeah. You brought up a great stat that
Metas had his longest loan streak of of
eight days here. It's interesting
because I remember earlier or maybe it
was late last year where it had its
longest streak of wins which was like 23
days in a row.
>> Yes.
>> And everybody. So in order to be part of
the investment for that, you got to this
comes with it as well. and July
historically historically even in
midterm years has been I think the
number four best month to invest in that
hasn't happened this year and so yeah
things are changing capex is a real
story AI is a real story I think the
geopolitical climate has played a major
part and it's just not US Iran right
Israel obviously as well with Netanyahu
being in America today but we just saw
Ukraine allegedly again allegedly Saudi
Arabia said they they they struck a ship
so there's just so much geopolitical
tension crude and this is interesting
right when we talk about crude right the
US and and the president with you know
every night 11 nights they were bombing
they were bombing they were bombing
Saturday they stopped Sunday they
stopped
>> the timing of it makes it very
interesting why
>> it's a big week right like if I if the
oil prices stay at 100 or stay elevated
what does that say for inflation when
you have the Fed chair that's about to
speak on Wednesday right if if we have
prices going up to 105. Does he raise
rates? Right. Does that meeting now
change and we raise rates? And we're
going to talk about a different story
next Monday if he says that they pause
to have peace talks. Iran has said there
is no peace talks. I don't know what
you're talking about. [clears throat]
Allegedly, there's peace talks and the
bombing is stopped for two days. Here
comes the Fed here on Wednesday. It
looks like oil prices got back down to
to 83. And so now the inflation talk
kind of eases which is when you talk
about I don't want to say manipulation
but the strategic timing. How's that?
Strategic timing is very interesting of
all this.
>> Very interesting.
>> Let me let me make an announcement to I
forgot to mention it's for general
admission tickets.
>> Okay.
>> So if you try to use it for VIP, it
won't work. So the code block
>> is for general. We're generous but not
that generous. General admission tickets
only, please. And I will say this
because I did say that I hate y'all so
much as far as those those that
>> feel so unlike you. I'm be honest.
>> But this this community,
>> it's heartbreaking.
>> No, this community, Market Monday's
community,
>> I I love you so much. I love you so
much. There we go. I love you guys so so
much. But it's
>> the other people that I hate so much.
>> You hate?
>> No, I hate them so much.
>> That's
you gotta hate. No, no, no, no, no,
[laughter] no. You gotta hate when
somebody tries to sink a ship of people
that are only here to help.
>> I feel you.
>> That's you're you're that's why I told
you before they they're actually Judas.
>> We had this conversation really cuz we
had this conversation.
>> No, they actually are Judas.
>> And what and my response to him was like
I just I never let negativity into my
inner matrix. And so I see it. I don't
pay attention to it because I know the
focus is the people that are watching
here. I know the people in EU, the Rep
Panda family, the Invest community
because we already see the amount of
people that are going to be in
attendance. So my focus is like how do
we make that experience even better for
those people? How do we make you know
what they're about to see, what they're
about to witness, what they're about to
feel even that more of an elevated
experience. So my focus is always on
that. I know. But that's what makes Ying
and Yang, right? A lot of people will
say like, "Yo, Rashad said it." I'm
like, "Yo, if he said it, then we said
it." You can't It's not I can't run from
him saying something. And like if he
says it then we said it. But that's how
a ying and yang I guess works. Like he
he gets to be that so I could be this.
>> Unfortunately [snorts]
it is a trauma response. That's
something we definitely share. You got
to use the hate to fuel you cuz I got
some of that hate last year and you can
argue last year was my best performance
on stage. So sometimes because the
energy never dies or dissipates, right?
For all my chemistry biology people. You
have to use that in order to make it
better,
make people more money. And that's
that's if I'm gonna be very honest, part
of the reason why I started doing the
Red Panda the Millionaire campaign. Um,
so don't hate anyone, my brother. I know
it's heartbreaking.
Trust me, I get it. But the other thing
is to level up. Oh, after this, I'm
letting you know I'm going on a personal
world tour. If it ain't Red Panda or
this show, nope. I Nope. I [snorts] done
gave all my information, my IP. Nope.
Sorry. Gotta learn when to pull back.
>> Gotta learn when to pull back.
>> And if you think it's tough now, wait
till next year. 42% chance of recession.
>> Well, let's talk about the chip. Let's
talk about the chip chip market.
>> Shout out to Norway in the check.
>> Um because yeah, the China chip market
surge.
>> We've been talking about chips for a
long time and we're seeing a pullback.
So, hey, what's the deal with the China
chip market surge? And is this something
to really be concerned about if if your
portfolio has SMH heavy or you're in the
chip sector heavy? Is it time to start
being concerned?
>> It's time. I mean, you always I wouldn't
say concerned, but you should definitely
be aware of what's happening. I think a
few things happened over the past uh
couple days and you might have missed
them. So, we'll go over them
strategically. Um SKH
uh signed a $500 billion deal with
Nvidia. Why is that important? SK
Highness is the leader in high bandwidth
memory. They control 60% of that market.
Nvidia obviously the leader when it
comes to GPUs and obviously one of the
top customers. What does that do from a
strategic standpoint? It makes them say,
"Hey, we're not just a customer anymore.
We're going to have to partner on
infrastructure going forward." What does
that do for the bottom line for Nvidia?
It brings down that that cost and it now
has a strategic partner that they can
build out into the future. I think it's
a brilliant idea. Second piece and this
is important. Micron, not Micron,
Samsung signed a deal, a $200 billion
deal with Broadcom. And why is that
important? Well, again, number two in
the high bin with memory uh sector is
Samsung, but part of this deal is not
just the memory piece. They've signed it
for packaging and manufacturing. So, we
talked about TSM earlier with packaging
and manufacturing. That is what they do.
They're the world leader. It's not even
a close second. The fact that Samsung is
saying, "Hey, we want to to do our own."
Number one, loosens a reliance on TSM,
but allows Broadcom to have a strategic
partner because they are making the
custom ASIC silicone for
uh Google when we're talking about TPUs,
right? Companies are now saying, "Hey,
Nvidia, the GPU is great. We can't
afford it. We want to do this internally
and have our AI stack right here within
our company." Broadcom sits right in
that market. So, if you're trying to do
custom, they can help with the custom
pieces. That's a strategic partnership.
I love it. What does it say for Micron?
Micron
has to have a very, very calculated next
move and I'll be interested to see what
that partnership is. Does it mean the
end for them? Absolutely not. They are
still one of Nvidia's biggest customers
because the the bandwidth memory
[clears throat]
uh demand is very high. So, I think
overall, has the demand changed? No. Has
the story changed? No. There are
strategic moves that are happening
inside of the book though. Now, this is
why I got a little bit of intellectual
smoke for Apple because they did
something.
There's a report allegedly. It was in
the uh the journal uh yesterday. It was
saying that there's a fight between
Micron and Apple. And the reason was
Apple was saying, "Hey, we have to raise
our prices on our next age of devices
because the memory shortage and the fact
that they've scaled pricing is going to
affect our bottom line." And I said,
"Okay, that's interesting." Right? The
company that used to dictate to people,
hey, whoever has the the lowest price,
>> that's who we're going with. And so, you
were the bully for 10 years. you chose
I'm going to use SK Hane or I'm going to
use Samsung or I'm going to use Micron
and whoever gives me the best deal I'm
going with. The tables have now flipped.
Now they create the price and now
they're saying hey well [snorts]
how come you're charging that much? In
fact, you're charging so much now we
have to charge our customers more. That
was the first piece. The next piece was
that again allegedly Tim Cook and Tim
Cook and the Apple officials have gone
to the White House to say look
>> we either
>> we either need to figure out what
they're spending this money on because
they're their profit margins are so high
either they're keeping it or they
they're price gouging. This is what
their claim is on Micron. Because of
that, they've asked now the president's
team to allow American companies to buy
Chinese memory chips. Why is that
important? Well, if the Americans are
allow companies allowed to buy a cheaper
chip, right, which now becomes a quote
unquote national security issue. It was
the reason why Nvidia couldn't sell
there, right? And now China said, "We're
not allowing you to sell and we're not
even going to buy." That changes the
dynamics. So either the White House is
going to have to decide allow Apple to
buy and allow other American companies
to buy at the cost of an American
company like Micron.
>> So but for Micron you had talked about
before as far as some people were saying
$1,600. Is that
>> is that how do you feel about that right
now?
>> I'm still at that number. I think 1,600
is still the number by the end of the
year.
>> Still feel comfortable with 1600
>> 100%. A couple of reasons why all those
things I just said to you tells me that
the demand [clears throat] hasn't gone
anywhere. Right. If the demand hasn't
gone anywhere and they're sold out to
2026 and potentially sold out to 2027,
that story doesn't change. Do I think an
administration will allow a company like
Apple to buy from a a Chinese
manufacturer when it comes to
>> that would be financial [__] treason?
>> Exactly. Now, if they don't allow it,
now what happens to Micron? Right. Once
they say that you can't do it, well,
back to the price that you're going to
pay until we figure out this bottleneck
situation. Now, CXMT
IPO today, it ran up 450%. Why is that
important? Well, the Chinese are saying,
"We're not going to use your memory,
Samsung. We're not going to use your
memory, SKHX. Micron, we're not using
yours. We'll build our own." And we just
went over this. When you're talking
about building at scale, that takes
time. When you're talking about building
with efficiency, that takes time. Right
now, these chips will only be used by
government officials. They're not
selling these to companies. It takes
money to build in infra infrastructure.
When you talk about capitals that's
being raised, think about how much money
Micron is now worth. A year ago, it was
a $200 billion company. This year, it
touched a trillion. This company IPO
today, it hit 8 billion. It was the
largest land company in the in the
country for the semiconductor space at 8
billion. Do you think they have to scale
to build out infrastructure to now
compete with trillion dollar companies?
Not yet. So, we just got to be mindful
of that.
The only people who are worried about
the destruction of SMH and Micron are
the people who are trading it and not
holding it. The value of the chips um I
mean I love the clip one before we even
did market Mondays uh AMD and video was
talked about in 2020. You can calculate
the returns from there. That's the power
of long-term holding. Do do I think
Micron will come down some more? Yes. Do
I think that the company's incredibly
valuable? Yes. But the only people who
are worried about it are in the trade of
it and not holding the stock. This is
not trading [__] Thursdays.
To change for market money is to hold
the equities forever.
>> Holy [__] Okay. Both
>> forever.
>> But again, the vision for them is not
can we win July, November, December. The
China's vision is can we win in the next
decade, 20 years from now,
>> right? Can we build our own stack and be
self-reliant? We don't need South Korea.
We don't need Taiwan. We don't need
America. Can we do that?
>> Independent.
>> Yep.
>> And that they're looking at 20 years
from now, not today.
>> But if you want to know what the market
is going to fall to in advance, the
months in advance, go to.com and join
stock club. Prices are I think I put out
120 prices and more to come. If you want
to know the stock club, red panda stock
club.
>> If you want to know where to get in, get
out. any contagion event that's gonna
and the other thing y'all listening to
too many people I'm not gonna fix any
mistakes from anybody who didn't make
their millions from this
sorry so whoever [__] up your
portfolio this me talking whoever [__]
up your portfolio don't come to me and
say we'll fix this with y'all weekly
rotation [__] now he got to be
diplomat
>> I'm Rockefeller
>> I don't have time for it if you [__]
up your portfolio elsewhere then go to
the person who [__] him up and Tell
them to fix it. I've been telling you
the whole no stock or no sector goes up
1,900% in perpetuity.
>> Y'all gambling.
>> And even with the person who say
somebody stole your money, y'all thought
it was cuz I made it look easy. Y'all
thought it was a bunch of me. It's not.
It's not.
I'll bulk record my [__] I was free
when y'all met me. I'm the only one who
say it. I'm the only still still
standing on it. You go back to the early
episodes. The what I loved then I love
now. You have to hold for long periods
of time. But some of y'all don't want to
hear it. And if you don't want to hear
it, that's fine.
>> One day I'mma call Rashad Bow offer.
Let's wrap this [__] up. Y
>> wrap it up.
>> Sometime like, okay, even AA and MJ had
a tumultuous little relationship, right?
They made Mike sit down. Okay. But then
when Mike came back, he said, "Well, you
saw my values when we left.
allegedly
>> the pip and bulls. Shout the pip. Love
you. I know you [__] dang with Satoshi.
It's different when Jordan in the league
and different when he leading the team
versus Scotty is doing it. I am begging
you also to the other part on the hater
part in light of DEI going away. There
are a lot of African-American people who
are paid agents of the state to tear
down certain movements. I proved that
before.
>> Oh yeah. The state the state
>> is wilder than ever.
>> I didn't say that. I said state ending
with the state. So, but do what y'all
want. After Investfest, I'm going to be
gone.
So,
>> oh man.
>> A red panda sale. No. Get get your
tickets to Investfest.
[laughter]
No. No. Uhuh.
>> Don't Mom, I'm gonna be okay. I'm gonna
be okay. Mom, I see I see where this is
going. Mom, Dad, I'll be okay.
>> Oil [laughter] Oil Marcus. Bill Marcus,
>> everyone's talking about oil going to
back to 100 a barrel. The number I said
at top of the year, clip my team, clip
this up before you get clipped.
>> 9350.
>> Allegedly,
>> they know allegedly. I'mma clip you if
you going to clip this up. I said
earlier this year 9350 was the key e
economic indicator. If I pay a premium,
you got to deliver at a premium, right?
9350 is a key level. We're at 8167. So
while he's manipulating the market and
choosing when to have a ceasefire and
when we going to engage in war, he's
keeping that number under 9350. There is
no oil issue to worry about. We do have
a tariff issue to worry about. The cost
of that war, we talked about it on
blackout being 100 billion. If it wasn't
for capex spend, we would be in a soft
recession or stagflation, which is
another word for the economy is really
[__] up right now. So yeah, there's
two parts to that.
>> Yeah. No, I gota finish that.
>> I I say you go.
>> No, you go. No, you go.
>> I was saying that there's two sides to
that coin, right? Because of the capex
spend, it is being there's like a
broadening out of the market. Like you
you'll hear that term a lot, especially
among analysts and pundits. And you can
kind of see it, right? Because even with
the pullbacks that we've seen in like
these sub sectors, obviously
semiconductors being one of them, the
S&P is still what a a few percentage
from being at it alltime high,
>> right? So it's it's not like
>> the MAX 7 used to carry the S&P, right?
It's 40% equally weighted of the S&P.
The fact that
>> pretty much I mean they're about trading
even. Tesla, Microsoft are obviously
down.
>> The fact Apple's up 25% which is which
has been pretty good. They've been kind
of trading sideways throughout the year
and the S&P has still hit all-time highs
through it all. So there is a broadening
story. I think that capex spend if it
wasn't being spent on AI then this would
just be revenue. Then we we'd have a
different story. You think recession
even with let's take the AI spend out.
You're talking about companies like
Amazon which will probably report
another hundred billion dollar quarter.
Uh Apple's doing a hundred billion
dollar quarters. you're seeing cloud be
increased that has some of it its
attributes inside of AI but it would be
an interesting [clears throat] time if
the the capex spend and I'll be what
will be the penalty when they say we're
not going to spend that much we're not
spending we're going to start cut
spending do we see the broading story
get crumbled and now it's back into max
sevens like what what do you what do you
think the the idea is around that
>> they're going to have to reinvest and I
get your point but that's because of the
way the S&P is structured like um when I
say the market is rigged to stay up, I
mean in terms of direction and the way
that they do the waiting of the S&P. So
even though the MAG 7 and the AI
components may be dragging down, it's
calibrated to make sure that the entire
ecosystem doesn't collapse post 1929,
post 2008. That's why it's not dragging
down as far. But it's a tail of the two
economies. Um, also at the same time,
the debt that we're spending is
exceeding the growth that we're netting
in the country.
That's scary. Like even the percentage
of cap spend and I love AI Allen Bubba
and Open AI even though you had to run
to Nvidia for 250 to get the data
center. If I have a machine that can
replicate God and tell you everything on
earth, why do I need to go get financing
from Nvidia? Flaw number one. and you're
rushing to go public and Anthrop's
eating your lunch, but all of y'all are
rushing to go public like how SpaceX
did. If the company is so valuable, the
real companies are keeping this [__]
private if it's of any value. Secondly,
there's a lot of mismanage and there's a
lot of espionage. And I keep bringing
this point up for a reason and to your
shirt. Allegedly, there's a lot of
Olivia Pope [__] going on right now
internationally that no one can speak on
out of fear. Um, a lot of our tech
secrets, even in the case that got
settled for all the IP that has ever
been uploaded by humans in history, have
been put into the LLM and the authors
and creators of it have not been paid.
So, I think it's a tailor to economies.
I think that that yes, the stock market
can be at an all-time high while the
economy is not doing incredibly well.
>> Damn. Uh Sam Alman said that we have
reached the moment of singularity,
meaning that AI has is efficiently
smarter than any human being living.
[sighs]
>> Well, make it smart enough so you have
to go get funding elsewhere.
Well, he, you know, he's in he's in DC
uh this week campaigning to get more
funds.
>> I think I think bigger and I said this a
few weeks ago, it's it's bigger than
funding. I think he's going to give
percentage away to to the United States
government.
>> Um so that will be guaranteed revenue
and guaranteed funding
>> if you're doing we'll see.
>> Let's we'll see.
>> Yeah, let's do lightning round if we can
before we before we bring the young man
up. So, let's do um
>> big tech AI spending.
>> All right. I thought about this and this
is important when we were talking about
um building homes and it dawned upon me
that this is what this feels like.
>> Do you have a pool?
>> Why you doing that? [laughter]
>> Yo, what's wrong with this?
>> Shout out to Bleak. Um [laughter]
this guy's crazy
when you're building a home and the
process is tedious. But the most
important lesson that I learned and I
you can attest to this as well is that
the the amount of capex that you spend
on building your home, it's tough to
estimate for. And so you keep spending
and you keep spending with the end
product being in mind, but it hasn't
come to reality until it does. And so
you're spending, you're spending, you're
spending. And I'm thinking to myself,
this sounds like the AI story, right? If
we thought about this, and I talked
about this Thursday night, this these
companies, this this capex spend is like
a construction site. And Meta is saying,
"Look, we're going to have to spend
more." Microsoft says, "We're going to
have to spend more." Google said, "We're
going to spend 140." Nah, we moved it up
to 205 billion. They're building,
they're putting out the money. They're
pulling out the money with the end
result that hasn't come to fruition.
Investors are saying, "Look, we need to
see the end result." They're looking at
it like, "We can see it. It's going to
take us more money to get to that point
to build it." and then the value can be
extracted from what we put together. And
so if you think of it in the terms of a
construction,
>> they're lying.
>> I feel like [laughter] well that part we
we can get to that part. But if that
that's what this this AI spend looks
like and I don't know when it slows
down. I I think this week won't be
anything different from what we saw.
Microsoft's going to say, "Hey, capback
spend is going up." Amazon's going to
say it. Uh Meta's going to say it. Uh
and Apple's going to say, "Look, we're
still at 2.5 billion. That's our capex
because them in terms of hyperscalers
and AI spending is a very different
scenario when you think about where
Apple sits there the toll booth. Why is
that? Well, if you have open AI, if you
have chat GBT, uh anthropic, if you have
Perplexity,
where are you using that on?
You're probably using it on one of their
devices. And so they're like, "Okay, why
would we invest it?" I know they're
coming to us to use it on their device,
which is why OpenAI said we have to
build our own hardware in order for them
to really take off and have some some
real revenue gains. They have to have
their own device because if not, you're
going to be living on Apple the same way
that all of us do when we go to the app
store. And they're going to get a p
piece of that and then they're going to
get a piece of the subscription that
y'all pay as well. And so if it's a
million uh people uh a month or it's a a
billion which is what uh open a got open
AAI got up to look that's revenue that's
coming in man. So it's a it's an
interesting story
>> if it's worth anything.
>> The banks JP Morgan would in would have
bought or built it. Uh going back to
government, certain governments
internationally would have bought into
it. Build it and they will come as a bad
business strategy. You still can't find
one person yet who can and I keep
bringing up this open AI running to go
public point because I saw the comment.
They're rushing because they need to
raise the capital because they are net
negative
as a result and they don't want to miss
their window because if a crash comes
then they won't be able to go public or
the valuation is going to be cut in
half. Kind of like what happened to
Stripe in 2022. You don't want to miss
that window. But you would have seen a
bunch of banks buy it. The com the
companies that have the cash on hand,
they would have put all the money into
it if it if the return was there. It's
not at this point. I'm going ask a
question again.
Can anybody in chat run their business
off of one LLM and then you just go to
the beach and catch vibes all day?
That's what we were promised. We're not
there
>> from from who? From any LLM.
Yo yo Claude Code is is pretty this is
and that's the part. So Claude Code and
and this is what they they're accusing
China of. They took Claude Cold, they
took Fable 5 and they said, "All right,
build us a system." They built the
system and now you you're seeing the
ramifications of it. Now you get a Kimmy
E3. They're taking Code Code and
building businesses from it. So the US
is like, wait, hey, you can't just take
our technology, build something from it,
a spawn of it, and say like that's your
new company. But that's kind of was the
purpose of it. I saw something.
>> Well, we well that's all alleged. But I
saw something today that was interested
and they said there's no regulation on
that component of AI yet, but eventually
they they're going to treat it like
pharmaceuticals
where you can't just take take this drug
bring and hey, we're going to put your
mark on it and we're going to sell.
There's going to be regulations. They
can come after you in lawsuits. That
hasn't happened yet. I think that's
where the future of this is headed
because I mean when you think about it,
Clark Cole can do a lot of stuff, bro.
Uh tech. Let's let's gota bring our
guest up. Big big tech AI. We just did
that. Um Tesla versus
Tesla versus
>> it it was a a good question. I think
that's fascinating. A person asked me
over the weekend if I'm investing in
Tesla, do I need SpaceX or vice versa?
Um respectfully with all the love of my
heart as I finished preparing for my
presentation in Atlanta, don't ask me
about SpaceX until March of next year.
>> [laughter]
>> It's It's millions of shares that are
about to be offloaded.
Um it is not time. I told you what my
son said the price is going to fall to.
We're almost at that price. Wait until
you have institutional buy in for a
company that is worth trillions but only
does 18 billion in revenue. No. And
please stop regurgitating my talking
points and yo they going to merge. I was
said that three years ago. I know. No,
>> SpaceX lost.
>> Don't ask me about space. It's in March.
>> They lost 1.2 trillion in value since
IPO.
>> Tesla.
>> Tesla is worth 1.2. They lost a Tesla.
>> They lost Tesla. Like an entire
company's market cap is what SpaceX
lost, which is
>> sometimes
>> invest festival one. I said you got to
look at the character of the founder.
Can I go through some things Elon
promised in their income? Uh 20 million
in annual car sales. Coast to coast
autonomous driving energy business will
be as big as automotive. Legacy Auto
will guard a business. Tesla's Tesla
Semi will take over freight robo taxis
by next year. That's four years he
missed that. Uh $25,000 model by 2023.
FSD robo taxi.
I'm tired, yo. Let's call it spade a
spade. Most of the things that he's
promised that he hasn't delivered on.
Starlink is the real gem of that. Now
the fact that he became a trillionaire
by not delivering on provinces and
getting all those government contracts
is an amazing feat in a business case
study to believe in. Uh yes Tesla still
a component in stock club but if you are
expecting space X to deliver 5x return
in the next year
>> you are smoking moon rocks. Yo
>> bro I watched somebody say it's going to
be a $20 trillion company in 10 years.
20 trillion. the largest company in
human history.
>> That sounds good.
>> No, it sounds ridiculous. But I mean, do
I believe
>> listen in the perspectives they had that
he's going to put data centers in and
make a lunar economy bigger than Earth.
If I said that, I would have got cooked
up.
>> He's got to Would people 10 years ago
believe that there would be 13 trillion
dollar companies?
>> Probably not. not.
>> So, I mean, but I'm with you. There
there's a there's a great Yahoo uh
finance article about the Cybert truck
being the the biggest flop in the
industrial
uh car ecosystem of all time.
>> Um Amazon's satellite phone network.
>> I just this is this is part of it, man.
This is this is the repercussion of what
Elon has done in terms of the quote
unquote terrestrial they call it not
lunar economy terrestrial economy.
>> Terrestrial. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> I I think this is uh
a fascinating venture. I would just say
keep my eyes on it. I'm still doing more
research on it. Um Starlink is
definitely going to be the leader in
that connectivity satellite lower
firmament space. But I do think it's
fascinating for Amazon to start to
venture out here. So just keep your eyes
on it. I'm I'm not the happiest with how
the stock has performed. But I do like
when CEOs try
to invest in other areas that others are
not looking at. Like kind of like the
blue ocean strategy. I love in the midst
of AI. They done their AI and capex
spend, but they're looking to another
revenue source uh for the future. Yeah,
it's it's I I mean I think there's a a
hardware component that has to come uh
along with this news because the the
filing is for them to have these
satellites in orbit by 2028 and they're
supposed to provide direct phone to
phone, voice calls, text messaging,
mobile data, uh emergency services and
coverages in areas without cell towers.
So there must be some hardware that's
coming along with this Amazon we're
going into space with satellites.
>> Stay tuned. South Korean stock market
fell 8% as well because of the chip
rally. So,
[snorts]
>> all right. Now,
>> how you feel, Rashad?
>> I feel good. I feel good, man. 6,000
people on the check in.
>> Love y'all.
>> God is good. God is good. God is great.
Um,
let's uh let's bring our guest up, shall
we?
There you go. Is he there?
>> Hello. [clears throat]
>> We can we can hear me. Y can't see me.
Camera's not on.
>> Let me see.
Let's see now.
Sorry, guys.
This is odd.
>> Mike, you want to bring him down to his
camera comes up?
>> Bring him down. We'll do the tech with
while we while he's figuring it out.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I was having tech issues
earlier. Well, T-Mobile had an outage
earlier today as well, so that affected
a few million people. So,
>> yo, it was crazy. Um, I was I was Yeah,
my phone.
>> What's up, my brother? How you doing?
>> How's it going? How's it going?
>> Had a little good, my brother.
>> No, we back.
>> Xavier Clemente, how you doing, man?
>> I'm doing good. How y'all doing? Rashad,
Troy, Ian, thank you for having me.
6,000 people in the chat. This is crazy.
Yeah,
>> W's [applause] in the chat. That's
that's what they say, right? W's in the
chat.
>> W's in the chat. Yeah. [laughter]
So, you know, we we we uh you you spoke
at a school um that we was at in the
Bronx a few months ago and it was it was
such an impressive story from an
entrepreneurial standpoint and and just
going to Investfest and how that's
actually altered the trajectory of your
life that we was like, man, it's just a
we want to, you know, highlight young
entrepreneurs, some people that are
doing well in the community, our form of
give back. Um, but I also just want you
to just kind of tell your story if you
can as far as how you got to market
Mondays.
>> Yeah. So, this is completely crazy cuz I
envisioned this literally the first time
I went to Investfest cuz I was watching
you guys before even going to
Investfest. But first year at
Investfest, I want to thank um Kevin
Riley for, you know, sponsoring our
Atlanta trip. Um, council member from
the Bronx. He invited us and about like
I think it was 70 other students
completely free five-star hotel and I
was able to actually go. I was invited
and that first year I had nothing to
show for it. I had no business. I was 17
years old fresh out of high school class
of 2024 and I just wanted to go and just
be around an environment of
entrepreneurs
highle individuals and actually learn.
So being there, I was just shaking hands
with everybody like I was, you know, I
was telling you guys earlier. Um,
I was trying to schedule calls with
people. I was trying to get on Zoom
calls, schedule this, try to see how
could I learn from somebody or get a
mentor, etc. And
that alone just led me to create
connections and actually interact with
certain people. But at Investfest,
like I said, I want to give a thanks to
Sherman Brown because he has a larger
network as well. And being there, I
actually met somebody who was involved
in a business I was interested in, which
I now run, Jotic Rentals. And ever since
then, we just stayed well connected. His
name is PJ. He's a mentor of mine.
And ever since then, it's just been on
since there came into Investfest the
next year. This is Investfest 2025. And
I was actually able to pitch my business
to you guys. you know, I was able to
pitch to Troy, um, MG, and I was
actually a winner of the youth
scholarship, pitching Jotic Rentals,
showing, um, my vision with it. What is
it I actually want to do, what's my
plan, how I actually want to scale, and
ever since then, I just been well
connected with the people around me.
Like I said, I want to give thanks to
Kevin Riley. Thanks to Sherman Brown and
as well as my high school principal,
Miss Bray from Bronxville Preparatory
Academy for bringing on Sherman Brown to
lead me to meeting Kevin Riley. So, it
was just all a bunch of steps and just
time time in the way. And now we're here
going into Investfest 2026 and
>> I'm on marketing Mondays with you guys
somehow, you know? So, it kind of mind
boggles me like I don't even understand
it, you know?
So, so just to just to so just to put it
in perspective before Troy goes, so you
how are you 19?
>> Yeah, I'm 19.
>> So you're 19 years old, coming out the
Bronx, you come to Investfest, you meet
a mentor essentially, you start an
exotic car rental business and then you
get um how much money did you get?
$5,000.
>> It was 1,000.
>> 1,000. Okay.
>> Yeah,
>> good enough. But you got the $1,000
[laughter]
>> and then and then you you you parlayed
that. But now you actually
>> have a successful exotic car rental
business.
>> Yeah.
>> And we actually used you because
[clears throat]
somebody I'm sure Troy will tell the
story, but somebody needed a car. So
>> straight out of high you pretty much
straight out of high school
>> and you're up and running
>> and you're you're like a a real
entrepreneur that's out here moving.
>> Congratulations. Thank you so much. I
appreciate it. So, yeah, it's like we're
actually serving real clientele. We're
actually providing these vehicles,
chauffeur services, daily rentals,
weekly rentals on exotic cars,
Lamborghinis, Ferraris, Rolls-Royces,
any vehicle you can name, we have access
to and we can put you in. Whether it's a
daily rental or a chauffeur, you know,
you got a date night, you want vacation,
airport drop off, you want to live that
luxury lifestyle. Sometimes people just
want it for the moment, you know. So,
we're here to provide that service and
it happened like this. And
>> it it's it's an incredible story. And
again, this this isn't just like some
theoretical like story we're telling.
This year, we have some kids that were
in our neighborhood going to the prom.
They called us day of, no joke, we day
of, hey guys, can y'all help? I need a
car.
>> AB was like, I know the person to call.
We we we call Xavier. He gets a card.
This is probably how many hours? Maybe
three hours, four hours maybe.
>> Yeah, like probably five hours max. Four
hours. Yeah,
>> five hours max.
>> You get the job done. This is the the
the idea of networking across. Prom
season is a big season for you. You just
came out of prom season. First question
is most people are thinking like, wait,
this is a 18-year-old kid, 19-year-old
kid. How was he able to get these cars?
So, talk about the process of having
your mentor explain to you the the game
and how this was on your vision board.
This wasn't something that came out of
nowhere. you were on your vision board
and saying, "I'm going to get there when
I'm 30." You didn't know you'd be here
at 17.
>> Not at all. So, yeah. Like I said, when
I actually met my mentor, once again,
his name's PJ at Investfest. Me and him
connected and I was telling him, "Yo,
look at my notes." I literally have in
my notes from about maybe 2023 or 2022,
saying I will own an exotic rental
business or it was under it was labeled
as future businesses and under it was
exotic rentals. and this is something I
thought I would have to scale into like
later on in the future. And he was just
like, "Wow, there's no way, etc." And
then as me and him continue talking, I
was like, "Wait, I think I know your
your your business." And me and him
actually had a convo because what's
crazy is this is such a full circle
moment. I tried to book with him for my
prom.
>> So, I actually tried to get a rental
vehicle for my prom. I was trying to get
a Lamborghini Huracan,
>> but I was 17 years old. So, you know, I
didn't meet the requirements. had no
full coverage insurance,
>> no 18, no 21 plus license, and then
>> you know, he ain't let it happen. You
know what I'm saying? He ain't give me
the L. I was a little tight, but I had
to go in my mom's car. But that was
cool. Feel me? But [laughter]
um so yeah, meeting um [snorts] meeting
the mentor, like I said, he was actually
able to show me the game and tell me,
you don't even really need to own these
vehicles. There's people out here that
have Lamborghini [clears throat] Uruses
that they don't even drive them
>> and they're just paying that monthly car
note
>> and it's just sitting there. It's a
depreciating asset. But a lot of people
do say vehicles are depreciating assets,
but when it comes into the rental game,
we could actually make them appreciating
assets as in
dealing with the expenses and then
everything profit from there. So just to
sum it up, investors having a broad
network and you can also, you know, own
the vehicles yourself as well, but
there's a lot of like, you know, using
investors, etc. where it's like there's
no risk on the table. Source the client,
you manage the vehicle, you're able to
get the job done.
>> Quick question for you. Can you for the
parents who may be watching with their
kids tonight, can you talk to us about
the power of youth
uh mapping out a vision plan and telling
parents not to limit the beliefs on
their children? Cuz you started
incredibly young and most people think
you have to wait till you're 30. But
talk to the importance about getting
started early as an entrepreneur and
what advantages the youth have o over
people that are older.
>> Yes, most definitely. So I always said I
always felt like I was behind. Even now,
I'll be like, I wish I started when I
was 13, 14 instead of playing Fortnite.
Like, I wish I was into crypto. I could
have been one of these crypto kids, you
know? But, I mean, it's it's all God's
time, you know. But, yeah, you really
have to do emphasize youth, financial
literacy in general because simply just
planting the seed in a young individual
could just blossom the whole entire
generation. So like my whole mojo and I
get this from Sherman Brown is I want to
um break generational curses and create
generational wealth, you know, because
I'm from the Bronx. I was born and
raised in the projects. But the ambition
and the the vision that I have for
myself being that people that had more
or that learned more or was experienced
poured into me at a young age, I now
open my mind to something completely
different from let's say the average
19-year-old. Whereas
>> I can vision my life being completely
different from let's say the average the
average Joe like you know let's say a
nineto-5 or corporate you know I
actually see life from a different
different perspective now that I zoomed
out and people were able to pour into me
from a young individual I mean from a
young age and that just goes to show how
much literally just a conversation a
conversation with a person could
completely change their life and that's
pretty much all it took for me going to
these events
Being partnered with Aim High and just
shaking hands, meeting all these high
level individuals show you there's so
much more to life if you just put your
head down and work towards something
greater than what is normal to
everybody.
>> Can I follow up real quick?
[clears throat]
>> Um, how I asked earlier, what's the best
way to network at Investfest, but walk
us through your blueprint for
um, how youked at Investfest and what
was your follow-up process after you
guys take notes on this.
>> Yeah. So the first year, like I said, I
had nothing to show for it. I was a high
school student, fresh out of high
school, actually, 17 years old, no
business,
nothing really much going on for myself
besides I was on 2K the last weekend
before Investfest weekend, you know. And
that being said, I went to Investfest
with the idea of I need to meet as many
people as possible just so I can
actually maybe just from a conversation,
I could step myself into a business or
gain an idea. So, with that being said,
I was just shaking hands with literally
everybody. There was not a person I was
walking by that didn't interest me. No
matter if they were wearing chains, no
matter if they were in a suit, if they
were in a sweatuit, if they were just
casually, I was shaking hands with
everybody cuz you never know. You
probably be standing next to a a nine
figure entrepreneur that's just chilling
in the lobby. So, I didn't neglect none
of that. I was just shaking hands with
as many people as possible and getting
the numbers, getting the details,
showing my willingness to learn and just
pretty much telling them like, "Okay,
this is what you do. How can I possibly
help you?" You know, rather than trying
to be a leech and just learn for for
free or yo, can you just spill knowledge
onto me? No, it's all right. Let's make
a transition here. Maybe I could
possibly maybe I know something that you
don't know in your endeavor. And it
might not be major, but it could be
something just
significant enough for you to want to
help me because you see the willingness
to learn in a 17-year-old. So since
then, just stood connected through text
messages and following up immediately. I
didn't wait to next weekend, soon as I
got back from to the Bronx, Atlanta, as
I was on the bus,
>> cuz we took a bus, that was a that was a
16- hour ride,
>> you know. That was a 16 hour ride. A lot
of people wouldn't be willing to do
that, but it was a 16- hour bus ride. as
I'm on the bus back, hey, can we do a
Zoom call Friday 8:00 p.m.? Like, I was
on it, you know? And I feel like that's
what you got to be cuz a lot of people,
they'll make the connection, but once
again, I get a lot of quotes from
Sherman Brown. The connection is in the
followup. You know, if you don't follow
up, it's just as equal as you never
talking to them in the first place.
>> So, I was just keeping that going,
keeping that flowing. And same thing
with Investfest. Um, the second time I
went 2025, I actually have something to
show for it. Yes, it wasn't flowing, but
it was showing that, okay, I actually
have something working in progress.
Let me show you my ideas. Let me show
you my my ambition and how I actually
want to scale this. Maybe we could work
together.
And then same thing, the connections and
the followup connect followup.
Your life could change just off meeting
somebody or shaking a hand.
>> I mean, what you said, that's what I
always say. I'm glad you said that
because I didn't I didn't talk to him
beforehand. He said, "How can I add
value to you? How can I help you? What
do you need help with?"
>> And that's what I always say. like
that's the right way to network. Like
you got to add value and this is
somebody that was at that time 17 18
years old
and had enough wisdom to lead with that.
So when I'm telling you guys this and
this is a success story it worked for
found a mentor. He's running a
successful business. He's 19 years old.
Like he say took a bus from the Bronx 16
hours on a bus. You gotta you gotta be
you gotta be hustle.
>> You gotta be a wolf out here to get this
money, man. That's what I [laughter]
always say, man.
>> It's not just gonna come to you just
because you go to Investfest. It's not
like a magical, oh, somebody's gonna
walk up to you with a check for a
million dollars. Like, no. You made half
the battle of getting there. The other
half of the battle is getting out there,
getting out of your comfort zone,
meeting people, talking to people,
following up. Like, you gotta be you
gotta go hard, man. Like, you gotta go
hard. Like this is a perfect example of
somebody that said, "I'm not coming all
the way out here for no
>> to waste time."
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, that that's a fact, man. I'm
looking at the chat, man. Shout out to
Aim High. You got You got some family in
the chat, man. They putting your
business up there, man.
>> They showing mad love in the chat. You
>> Before we I mean, we spoke to you in the
Bronx at the end of the school year. We
spoke to you before you came on here a
little bit. We talked about the
seasonality of your business. I know
like it right now might be wedding
season, you know, when we go back to
school it might be homecoming. You just
came out of out of prom. All these
seasons are bringing different
opportunities in terms of revenue. How
are you managing that side of it? Right?
Because you still are very young, but
you already have the the the
entrepreneurial spirit. You already have
the wisdom, you have the mentorship. How
you dealing with, hey, I have a profit
and loss statement now. How how's the
business side going for you?
>> Right. Most definitely. So that's
something I'm really trying to emphasize
moving forward and as of now. Um
definitely trying to keep track of that
because there is some there is some
losses. You know there is some big wins
and that's going to be with any
industry. You know I notice a lot even a
lot of people with my age is a little
bit off topic but we all want we want to
we want the view from the top of the
mountain but we don't want to climb. So
with that I mean is
>> we don't want to deal with the losses.
We don't want to deal with the errors.
cuz we don't want to deal with the
losing money, but that just comes with
it. And when it comes to the finances,
I'm just looking to really build as much
capital to the point where I'm actually
to able to buy my own vehicles to where
everything is profit from. Then for like
let's say for simple example, I love the
the example of a Mercedes-Benz S580,
very luxurious car, etc. Goes for about
let's say 65,000. You get the car, the
car notes about, let's say, $1,000 a
month. Insurance $500. That car right
there is costing you $1,500 a month
aside from the down payment, but you
could rent that car out $400 a day.
>> So 48 126, you're above break even.
You're $100 in the green and that's 4
days out the month. Imagine if you rent
that car out 20 times on average for the
month. Now that's 20 times 400. You're
at $8,000,
>> you know, in total. And once again, your
expenses is only 1,500. And yes, it
sounds very, you know, beautiful and
okay, cherries and blossoms, but you
know, there's down um there's downsides
where let's say potential accidents in
the client or you got to deal with a
curb rash or somebody tries to something
extravagant or something happens with
the vehicle,
transmission, oil change, this that and
the third. But that's pretty much the
blueprint I'm trying to follow. So, my
whole idea right now is how can I save
enough capital to the point where I'm
able to get my own Mercedes-Benz S580 so
that I can actually instead of being on
the sidelines and working with my
investors, but actually now really be in
the game.
>> Can I just ask a followup question? So,
let me just the business model
standpoint. So, explain to me how to So,
okay, I have a let's say I have a um a
Porsche, right? and
>> my car note is $2,500 a month. But like
you said, I mean, the theory is that if
I could rent it out for a couple days,
then I don't really have a car note cuz
it's paying me. So, I know, okay, I know
that I want to do that. That makes
sense. How do how do I connect with you?
Like, do you recruit people or is it
like how do you connect with those
people that's looking to rent their cars
out? And then the next question is
you're like the middleman in this
situation. So you pay them and then you
take a percentage of like if I pay if
somebody pays 3,000 then you would take
like a percentage of that and then give
them the rest. That's how that works,
>> right? Yeah. So it could work like that.
So for example, let's say
let's say you're an investor. It would
work in a scenario where it's like,
okay, I give you a percentage, I'll pay
you. I'm managing the vehicle. You're
giving it to us. We're going to rent it
out. We're going to deal with the
clients. We're going to deal with the
the oil changes, etc. But that's that's
negotiable. Like that's not mandatory.
There's options where okay, we manage
the vehicle, but you deal with all the
maintenance or you deal with the
expenses, etc. Depending on the profit
split that we do, whether it's a 7030 or
let's say a 60/40, you know, all of that
changes the the inside of the game
whether or not, okay, we're going to
deal with the expenses or we're going to
deal with the mechanical work of the
vehicle or do you even want us to manage
the car in the first place? Do you just
want us to send you clients your way?
But there's different like loopholes
through it all. And to go back to your
question.
Yeah. So it would work in a way where
it's like, okay, I pay you or depending
which way we agree upon because there's
actually a lot of ways to, you know,
maneuver it depending on what you're
comfortable with because that's really
what matters most.
>> And then how do you get the people? How
do you how do how do you get the car
owners?
>> Right. So, believe it or not, somebody
actually about 2 days ago reached out to
me first saying, "Hey, I already have
vehicles in Miami that I rent out, but I
live in New Jersey. I wanted to know if
possibly I wanted to grow my fleet in
New York. Would you be able to assist
me, etc. I really don't want to manage
the car. I don't want to deal with none
of it. Um, I just want to make the
purchase, get the car, and then pass it
on to you guys. You guys manage it, rent
it out, source the clients, and then pay
me. Could we come up with a profit
split, etc." So, that's one scenario. We
talked on the phone, they're looking to
buy the car, etc. We'll move forward.
That's one scenario, like I said. And,
um, another one would be
referrals. So, investors would, let's
say, have friends. For example, if
Rashad, you came to me first and you
seen success with us having a vehicle,
us managing your vehicle. You have Troy.
You'll be like, "Yo, Troy, I have this
um this guy just rentals and they rent
out my vehicle for me. manage me and I'm
just cash flowing every month. You know,
it's just
like recurring revenue to you and you
know, you're not dealing with none of
the headache aside from the fact, okay,
maybe if the car was to get in an
accident. Now, Troy, Troyy's like, "Wow,
this looks beautiful. I want to get a
vehicle as well." And then it's just a a
pattern like that. Or you could even co
call, you could see somebody in the
street and just simply be like, "Hey, do
you do you rent this vehicle out or how
how often do you drive this car? Does
this car really sit under your garage
and just collect dust or do you actually
put it to use?
>> And then from there just you propose
them with the idea. Wait, whoa, I come
out of pocket $4,000 a month for my
Lamborghini and you're telling me if I
rent it out for four days, I pretty much
drive the car for free.
Sounds like a pretty good deal to me.
>> Yeah,
>> that's good.
>> It's good. I I do have a follow I got a
follow with you about invest. What do
you say to the person who may be shy or
they don't want to go talk to everyone
in the lobby or in the venue? What do
you say to them and how limiting that
can be if they're not an extrovert or
put themselves out there like you did?
>> Yeah. So, let me just keep going back to
Sherman Brown. He says, "Be the
thermostat, not the thermometer." So,
with that being said is you set the
tone. You don't adjust to it.
You walk in the room, believe it or not,
>> be the energy.
>> Believe it or not, I'm sitting here
waiting for you guys to pull me in, and
I'm just like, "Wow, 6,000 people." I
was just texting one of my friends. I'm
like, "Whoa, this is this is different.
This is, you know, something I actually
dreamed of. I'm actually living in the
dreams I once, you know, slept on, which
is kind of crazy how fast time moves."
And I was just in here talking to myself
like, "This is my space. This is my
space. I do this. This is normal to me.
This is going to be normal. This is the
life I asked for." And just putting that
in your head, it leaves an imprint where
it's like it's real. You don't have to
be shy. You don't The space is yours.
You're just as equal as everybody else.
Maybe somebody learns more. I mean,
maybe somebody knows more or they have
more money or they have more access to
capital or they know a person that
completely
uplift them and you don't. It doesn't
matter. We're all equal to one another.
We're all here to help, you know. So,
just be the thermostat, not thermometer.
You know, set the tone. Don't adjust to
it. The space is yours. Make the most
out of it.
>> There you have it. Please, please tell
the people your business,
>> where to follow you, how they can
contact you, how they can get a car from
you, how they can give you their cards.
Like, give the whole business. Give your
business pitch.
>> Yeah. So, right now, Jotic Rentals, you
could DM us on Instagram. There's the
business card right here. Jotic Rentals.
It's Jay and literally exotic rentals
right there. You could DM us. We could
source you a vehicle. We could get you a
vehicle whether, like I said, a date
night, vacation,
wedding, prom, graduation, chauffeur,
etc. We can service you with as well as
email is jxotic rentals1gmail.com.
>> We here. We have all types of vehicles.
>> What area is? What area is? Tri-State.
>> Yeah. So, let me mention that as well.
Thank you for bringing that up. We have
we really focus on vehicles in New York,
but we have vehicles in Miami, Houston,
LA. So, if you're from New York and
you're going to Miami for a weekend, we
could get you the car in New York and we
get you the car in Miami. So, we could
get you dropped off and let's say a
Lambo to the airport right now, take you
to JFK and then get you picked up from
Miami and another Lambo. You get what
I'm trying to say? So, it works for a
circle. We could make we could make this
happen. However,
>> my boy Xavier love his Lambo. was to the
airport. It's crazy.
>> The 589, man.
>> It's been a pleasure. Shout out to Aimh
High, too. Aim High is an organization.
>> Um, shout out to Kevin. I don't want to
forget. Tell Can you tell them who runs
a AMH High?
>> Yeah. So, Sherman Brown, the CEO of AIM
High. Shout out to him. He deserves it.
>> Shout out to Sherman Brown.
>> Deserves it.
>> Shout out to Kevin Councilman Kevin
Riley. Yes.
>> They bring, I think, like 70 kids.
>> They got a hundred coming. They 100
coming this year. Um, which is
incredible and and we we will talk about
that. But you're going to be at
Investfest this year as well. So when
people see you, right, they should
approach you and really give them
pointers like how you should take in
this moment. I think that's important. I
just want to say I'm proud of you
because we've watched this happen over
three years. The Bronx is proud of you
for sure.
>> All right. and we gonna make sure that
this thing really scales and becomes the
business that you thought it was when
you wrote it down on your your your your
memo pad saying like this is going to be
my business of the future, man.
>> Yeah. I'm interested in, you know, any
additional info, whatever. I'm addition
I'm
I'm welcoming it all if you get what I'm
trying to say. Like any conversation,
any help, any assistance or any way I
can help one another or bring somebody
on, I'm willing I'm willing to do it
all. You know, I'm always willing to
learn. I'm always willing to help
another. And I feel like that's the only
way we grow. So, it's the only option.
>> I'm proud of you, man.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Thank you.
>> I'm proud of y'all.
[laughter]
>> Thank you.
>> Definitely.
>> We'll see you next week.
>> All right. Okay, man.
>> Crazy. Amazing energy. Clap it up for
him, yo. For the Hudpa. The
>> Go for it, man. Like you can't go to a
conference and sit against the wall and
not talk like everyone in chat based off
that. You got to talk to 500 people
while you're there.
>> Leave the how can I help you?
>> He's been consistent since the day I I
met him.
>> From the first invest three years ago,
he's been the same energetic,
goal- driven, focused, super disciplined
young man since the day we met him. He
actually was at the high school uh where
our curriculum was at at we were having
curriculum day and they were talking
about their business plans. He came in
and spoke and then he started giving
advice to the the young adults that were
there. He'll be there again giving
advice to the young adults. This is this
is what it looks like when community
builds together. Man, I'm super proud of
him. And again, shout out to Ahigh and
Sherman for all they do cuz when you
watch the group of young adults that
they bring and when they present, I sat
here like,
>> "Oh, we got some work to do up here in
Greenberg. We got to we got to get to
that level, which is great. I love it.
>> Shout out to the Bronx, man. Shout out
to Aim High.
>> That's what it's about. And that's what
Investfest is about. [laughter] That's
what Investfest is about.
>> We end on a peaceful note
>> for sure.
>> A story of love.
>> A story of love, man. Yeah, man. It's
been real. Shout out to Atlanta. You
know, we love you guys so much. Atlanta,
you know,
>> could never turn Atlanta against us,
man. Like Atlanta,
>> please. Too many too many memorable
moments.
>> Um,
>> and more to come.
>> Time.
>> Yeah.
>> And more to come.
>> Please wear black tie for VIP night.
Please. [laughter] Let's not make
>> that include black shoes. I'mma say it.
That include black shoes. No Air Force
ones. No Air Force Jordan ones. World
Cups.
>> No black forces.
>> American Cup. America Cup. [laughter]
>> Dress. My bad. America. I'm I'm tired
clearly. No America cups. Okay. Right.
>> Dress shoes. My
>> Yeah,
>> y'all got them. Y'all got them. But
don't tell us you don't got them. You
got them.
>> That's a fact, man.
>> Every every man should have a suit. If
you don't have a suit, this is your
opportunity to buy a suit. Every man
should own at least one suit. Every
woman should Women kind of have it easy
because you could wear a lot of
different things as a woman.
>> I don't know if they got it easy.
>> We not
the dress code. The dress code is you
can wear a skirt. You you don't got to
wear a gown as a woman. You don't have
to wear a gown.
>> You can wear a nice skirt. You can wear
like women they're dressed
>> for a black tie event. A skirt
>> if you look women dress a dress a dress
a dress.
>> Okay. That's what I'm saying. It's
different. No, we can't say cuz if they
show up in a sundress that's going to
>> Nobody's going to wear a sundress.
[laughter] Nobody.
>> We got to be very
>> They may be outside the VIP looking for
an investor.
>> They thought it was a singles lounge.
>> You see what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. Shout out to y'all who gonna be
SpaceX at Investfest. You gonna fall for
some of them loses in the lounge, my
boy. Be careful the perspectus.
>> Lounge.
[laughter]
>> Blackout. Very important episode of
Blackout. We got We going
>> Man, we we got to talk about the Nolan
Nolan um
>> Wells
>> Wells case for sure. That is extremely
disturbing. Um but we got uh Teslan
Figaro. if you don't know her, she's a
political um analyst that's um very educ
educated when it comes to politics.
>> So, I got a lot of questions for her
about that the voter rights thing. They
trying to make people have passports
now. Now, now they trying to do the
passport thing. Half the country don't
even have passports.
>> Yep. Yep. The the Real ID was the first
inkling that I knew that was going to go
this way. The the autopsy,
>> we got to talk about it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So once again, thank you to Block.
They're sponsoring 200 tickets. You can
go to investfest.com and get your
ticket. Enter code block for general
admission ticket. The locks event is
next Thursday. Um $35. Get your tickets,
the limited seating for that uh preview
of the documentary and then the fireside
chat with the guys. Nightife, go to
investfest.com. Tick, click the link for
the nightife vibe if you want a party on
Saturday and Sunday. Sunday is a mansion
party for 50 people. 50 people only.
Um,
>> where we get tickets for that at? I got
to put my bid in. Hey, if you on my uh
guest list, let me know now tonight.
Otherwise, you won't be there. I'm going
to turn my phone off Sunday.
>> And and and hopefully this weather holds
up so we can we got something dope that
we doing tomorrow.
>> Marketing Mondays.
>> Hopefully.
>> Yeah. We'll be able to have some fun.
>> Talk about it Wednesday
>> for sure. Or not.
>> Traveling mercies. Traveling Mercy's
man. Y'all be good. Happy birthday. It's
happy birthday in advance. Um it's
crazy. She uh every year I get a
Father's Day card from her and they're
always hand every time your mom sends a
card is handwritten which is a lost art.
She still writes handwritten notes and
text me like these most incredible text
messages. So I thank her wholeheartedly.
Uh happy birthday in advance. Ian, your
birthday is Saturday, my brother. I want
to wish you a happy birthday uh right
here for all the 82 babies. We
appreciate and we love you, my brother.
A Leo season is full of fact, Mom. I
know you watching, so we gonna wait.
Your birthday shout out be next week,
Mom. Just
>> shout.
>> Happy once again, happy belated birthday
to my niece. Happy birthday to my mom.
Happy birthday to Ian. And happy
birthday to all the Leos out there
>> for sure
>> that's uh that's out there. that's
moving and grooving.
>> Shout out to Ivy. Ivy birthday on August
1st, too. Oh, also too, two two more
people. I will be uh promoting your
booth if you're in Red Panda membership
privileges. Submit your business and
send your booth number. I will be there
on Saturday. Try shot. I'mma try and
bring some lights and equipment with me
when I'm out the country for Monday. I'm
try
[clears throat]
>> phone in from the yacht.
>> Please don't upset nobody this week
because otherwise I'mma call off. So,
[laughter]
>> we keep y'all think pieces.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Shout out. Go uh check
out our episode with Big Bank that
dropped. Go check out our episode with
decisions decisions that dropped.
>> Keep it proud of Sweetie with with
Crystal Renee. That That was a dope
conversation. Go check it out, man.
There's a lot of content out there. Uh
and be be mindful of when you clip those
those episodes up, please. [laughter]
And when I see you,
>> okay,
>> thank y'all for coming out. God bless.
Good night. Y amazing. God is good.
We'll
>> see y'all Wednesday. Invest in the
indexes.
>> Mike, fade the black right here, Mike.
[laughter]